normalement on est reparti à fonctionner
il va falloir que je
j'ai besoin de deux petites minutes pour
récupérer tout ce dont j'ai besoin comme
on se faisait le speed run juste avant
donc laissez moi deux petites minutes
pour mettre l'échiquier pu après
récupérer les caméras
de toute façon là le temps le match va
durer quatre heures j'ai envie de dire
on ne va pas raté grand chose
si ce n'est rien d'ailleurs
j'avais oublié que j'étais pas connecté
avec
avec mon compte
c'était pas de bol le
vent de façon le match n'a pas commencé
je vais suivre wesley
l'échiquier qui caries
ça c'est cool je vais aller récupérer
les caméras
la cave est un peu basses ouais mais ça
c'est rien ça ça c'est rien ça c'est
rien on va récupérer les cartes des
joueurs et donc c'est la finale du
speech est donc ça va mieux joué que les
tours près semble que les tours
précédents demi finale déjà dit qu'ils
étaient quand même venus avec avec un
jeu très sérieux et ses ouvertures
savait pas mal joué aussi côté un
côté os les attendait
côté ouest la sarine
je vais récup les calmes
et on va être bon
ok
ok mickeal
me canonica l'on va pouvoir récupérer
calmes
le match a pas commencé en fait je suis
en train juste 2
organisée pour avoir les choses bien
comme il faut
quand ils sont pas tous les deux
installés
peut on récupérer qu'un des deux
déjà recupyl carreau
ça va être une première chose
je peux concentrer sur eure
du délire
klein déjà hikaru et wesley on va
récupérer ces
on va récupérer ça et maintenant
qui va arriver
c'est dur à savoir laquelle des deux cas
mais la sienne en fait
je n'arrive pas à savoir wii va être
assis
bon
le match commence en retard c'est déjà
une bonne chose ce n'est qu'une finale
ça paraîtrait logique de mettre le coup
on voit dix minutes en retard
ça commence bien
ça commence bien vite bien
d'une veille faire l'exploit de faire
nul est
assez ceux-là en finale 1 spalding
pas trop ce qu'ils font en fait
cam de saut
c'était le risque
et une chance sur deux en fait
je crois que ça a commencé
je crois que ça a commencé en fait
ouais ça a commencé au c'est terrible en
fait il est venu s'asseoir et ça a
commencé instante
en tout cas en gros je vais rappeler les
règles pour tout le monde donc là on va
avoir ils ont joué pendant 1h30 en 5 + 1
puis ils vont jouer
une heure en 3 + 1 puis une demi heure
en bullet
en gros ça va jouer très probablement
dans la dernière demi heure c'est quand
même souvent le cas
donc juste forez pour les gens qui
veulent regarder qui ont du temps devant
eux qui veulent savoir comment comment
s'organiser en gros ça va terminer vers
22h et le gros du suspense va être entre
entre 21h30 et 22h
en gros on va dire 21h15 ça peut être un
petit peu avant donc en gros si si vous
avez pas mal de choses à faire ce n'est
pas quatre heures devant vous vous
pouvez noter revenir vers 21h15
ça devrait être le moment où c'est chaud
pour ceux qui ont le temps
bah écoutez ça va durer quatre heures
donc c'est des partis qui s'enchaînent à
une heure et demie en 5 + 1 l'important
c'est un peu diluée tu sais jamais
vraiment ce qui est important par
important
à
on sait jamais vraiment ce qui est
important pour importante elle est
partie en tout une importance similaire
après pour la dynamique de match
évidemment il faut pas commencer à être
quatre cinq points derrière ça peut
devenir dangereux après on a vu que
c'était possible de remonter je crois
qu'à roanne est à -3 contre maxime il
est remonté
et donc on va voir le score semble un
peu mal mal cadrés
et donc on va voir comment on comment ça
se passe mais c'est pour vous expliquer
un petit peu le
pas le délire se serait pas le mot mais
mais vous expliquer un petit peu comment
suivre ces matchs
donc la première partie c'est une
sicilienne en une position
intéressante les blancs un tube plus
mais le pion des quatre est bloqué ils
ont mauvais fou
tu es tout seul au casse non je suis en
casque en duo avec comme invisible qui à
ma gauche là derrière le drapeau du
pakistan
et il fera peut-être quelques
interventions
on croise suite il s'enlève des fois ci
c'est qu'armand avantage hikaru ici
le carrier pourrait revenir
éventuellement sur des cinq aussi un
jour la tour va venir en des huit on va
mettre la pression sur le pion des
quatre
le fou peut venir en f pour couvrir la
et car on doit probablement regarder si
peu à les mener une attaque en force
donc la fouge et sain qui veulent
échanger ce les foules malgré les
avantages des espaces c'est vrai qu'ils
sont fous avaient du mal à trouver de la
vie est fou prend g5 qui veut pouvoir
avoir cavaliers prend et venir
attaquer gshc ff7 et sur h6 il doit
vouloir à il n'a pas cavalier katia dame
prend donc h six cavaliers f3 il va
falloir revenir en f3 et les noirs vont
jouer pour cavaliers cette cavale et f5
lecavalier défendra g7 il attaquera des
quatre colonnes c est en faveur des
noirs et malgré le pion plus sa position
est difficile à jouer sept tours angers
4 peut se retrouver mal
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
que 7 tours g4 qui était qui paraissait
visuellement bien placé peut se
retrouver très mal
donc c'est pas clair il yad'un côté
pions plus mais à sept tours bizarre qui
va avoir un problème en quatre tours ces
six tours ces huit tours ces deux
là position
paraissait offrir plus qu'elle n'en
qu'elle n'en a donné aux blancs
hikaru qui est un petit peu mécontents
je pense il a faim regarder un petit
coup au plafond côté hikaru
calais h3 ni veut revenir en f4
peut-être des vitres qui peut partir
donc l'on menace cavaler prendre 5 avec
les noirs pour jouer sur ce clou âge
et qui a valu à quatre n'est pas dame
prend des cats à cause de carélie j'ai
six échecs et tout reprend des quatre
importants
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya pas
cavalier e 2 à cause de cavaliers prend
1,5
donc hikaru a l'air assez des galas
calmes
et ça peut se comprendre parce que ça
tours angers 4 est vraiment mal placé il
réussit pas à créer de menaces en fait
s'ils voudraient va voir tour j'ai trois
dames g4 mais ça doit être au long tour
g3 qui est prend des quatre dames j'ai
quatre cavaliers f5 couvre couvre et
attaque donc il lui manque un tempo pour
ça il n'a pas cavaliers detroit et
cavaliers des quatre et il n'a pas
cavalier de ja cavalier e 5
donc en gros une position qui paraissait
très prometteuse pour les blancs
est assez pénible ici à jouer il n'a pas
des saints qui a valu aux 5
est en fête r
voici et qui est en train de faire un
bon début de match une bonne première
partie
position étrange 1 parce qu'il ya
vraiment ce pion plus pour les blancs et
une position qui semblait ne pas pouvoir
être moins bien ce n'est pas clair clair
parce qu'ils avaient cette casse des
cinq là problème le problème structurel
le mauvais fou pour les blancs mais
finalement c'est en train de tourner
pour wesley hikaru peut-être des gens
sua en ce début de match
wells a su une minute une minute 16
wesley qui joue vite en ce début de
match et qui met déjà la pression sur
son homologue américain hausse a su côté
américain je suis forcément côtes
américains puisqu'il y en a deux
mais ça sue côté tsm je crois qu'il est
dans les locaux de tsm laïque à roue
et on nous parle de cavaliers h5 qui
peut être un coup intéressant mais on
peut éventuellement juste faire tour g8
et on n'a pas réglé l'os problème hausse
c'est dur pour le chaos il n'est pas
dedans
il a déjà et en sueur au tour précédent
contre le joueur chinois
ça là
ça fait mal
ouais c'est terrible
c'était un village où un coup on n'a pas
vu il a joué dam des trois
alors il veut cavaliers prend 1,5 des
prend 1,5 dame prend des trois échanger
et sur cavaliers prend des quatre qui
doit vouloir tour des seins
et cavaliers f3 et le rap sion prend là
la dame sera protégé c'est un subterfuge
à ces marins trouvé par paris car ou
ouest et qui calcule un ouais c'est là
qui doit qui doit chercher
donc cavalier prend des quatre tours d
un peu être un roi g8 est possible pour
s'enlever des cavaliers g6 non il rentre
dans la finale oui oui c'est quand même
pour être bien sûr une petite nul ça ne
se refuse pas
bon là il ya plein de manières de faire
nul des deux côtés
d'ailleurs la drau est proposée par
hikaru est acceptée par par wesley
vizela nul ça ne leur fait pas peur
et on y croit les amis encore et encore
et c'est là berlinois ski par une anti
berlinoise de wesley wesley qui suit les
préceptes
ça échange tous ces cas tout ça est très
théorique la dame qui vend aux doses
petit robe petit rock ça va partir
là ça va cain normalement
peut-être fou b6 et un coup aussi fou g4
pourquoi pas ça peut se réfléchir avec
grand roque il ya des options pour
hikaru qui réfléchit déjà
fou aussi une autre option à noter
qu'après bk tueur a jamais vraiment de
france et 4e en france et 4 to b 6,6
assessing qu un important de voir ses
petits jeff piéjos à gauche à droite
donc on peut éventuellement faire b
quattro fou p6 kebede 2 d'ailleurs c'est
jouer un ses vues instantanément par
wesley et peut-être du cavalier bd dos
pour sûr fou prend avoir cavaliers prend
et taper la dama et el loco le fou en b6
donc et les deux peut être une option
peut aussi faire petit rock un fou prend
pions prend et ses six co qui menace
ouais c'est qu'il peut aussi calculer
bessines qu avec avec un problème et il
joue à trois
pas piquée des hannetons alors x 3
l'idéal est tout bête c'est bessines qu
un tap tap
ça tape ça
tape
et il joue ici le coup eux quatre
alors 4s que c'est fort ou pas alors
l'ordi donne déjà
écrasant pour les noirs après pions
prend il veut quoi j'aurais pas vu un du
coup vous prendre d'un premier grand
roque
la prépa de wesley à la poubelle
mais en vrai c'est très chaud puis on
prend comprendre dames prendront rock
petit rock
juste sordide fait du cavalier e 5 et
tomates à la dure mère est à 8 est
complètement coupée en fait le problème
c'est que le cavalier b1 rentre pas en
jeu le x 3 et à la poubelle la tour
entre par es tu avec trois pièces de moi
c'est terminé pour wesley
homé phase terminée c'est pas encore
fait quand même et un peu de défense
mais c'est mérité s'y perd beaucoup trop
pleutres dans la première partie il va
peut-être le payer
alors que thierry du 59 et très chaud
j'ai envie de te donner rendez vous aux
championnats du monde de rapides et de
blitz satirique on verra si quand tous
les joueurs sont à 100% hikaru reste le
meilleur j'ai peur que tu sois déçu mon
petit chéri
j'ai peur d'une grande déception pour
toi avec une nouvelle fois un titre de
champion du monde qui pourraient
s'échapper
bon là l'idée principale probablement
c'est fou c'est un fouet f4 et cavaliers
des 2 pour revenir après su repousser un
tu files le pion aux 4 était et est dans
le caca mais j'imagine que tout revient
au quai juste haut rhin et qui avait les
prend 1,4 dame prend 1,4 d'un point 4.4
tour d un matin facile un premier rang
jade couloirs raides donc sûrement fou
c'est un cavalier au quat'sous f4 et
essayer de défendre
je te rappelle les carreaux numéro en
blitz est en rapide alors revoir les
classes ont eu beau faire on en reparle
on en reparle fin fin du mois thierry ne
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer ne t'inquiète pas ne
t'inquiète pas
fou c'est ou non à contrecoeur c'est sûr
que c'est le premier coup qu'il avait
mis là il a cherché mieux
en fout.ce et uno
sinon cavalli ou quatre fois f4 mais
ouais c'est pas si alarmant je suis pas
si alarmiste l'ordi et très alarmiste
mais tu auras du à cuatro dû cavaler à
treize cavaliers c'est quoi trop
tu survis quand même
mais ça pourrait changer les dames est
était trop en retard
ouais faut f4 assez sûr je pense
tu dois gagner des temps
on va éval tu peux tu peux l'avoir sur
surface comme sur surchasse officiel et
sur toutes les autres chaînes en fait je
suis le seul qui la met pas
et tu peux la voir un
tour des trois ça fait mal à jouer trois
tours détroit le truc c'est que
t'arrives pas à terminer de
développement
dame e2 alors il veut quoi il veut faut
prendre trois pions prend 3 à quel point
m 2 où la wii s'est terminée vous
convaincre de dame prend 1,2 et oui
c'est dead ça fait mal
wesley so dominé en ce début de match
hikaru qui fait mal à la première bien
fait pour lui quand même tu peux pas
laisser filer des positions avantageuses
comme ça
et jouer trop vite pour la dhr au
bébé simcoe mettre le fou en baisse est
dans cette position ça c'est typique de
ces foulées cinq échecs fin typique
fait les blancs ont essayé de prendre le
132 temps pour pouvoir sur ses prêts en
reprendre de ces et s'assurer un bon
contrôle du centre avec un 2-2 2-0
centre entre guillemets mais les noirs
pourront contre-attaqué ce centre ici
cavalier e 5 peut être un coup
intéressant l'idée sûr qu'ils allaient
prendre jouer pions prend aidé avec les
pions doublé de taper sur la colonne des
je sais pas si vous avez dans votre lg
comme cavalier e 5
avril fait des 4
et tour ses huit bons
toujours eu du mal à juger ses positions
là avec les blancs tu as l'impression
d'être bien parce que tu as tes tâter
puntos quoi au centre donc ça c'est un
point très positif
mais en réalité c'est pas simple à jouer
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre d'ailleurs
donc l'idée évidemment surtout plombés 5
c'est qu'elle va les prendre quatre ça
c'est assez
facile le pion attaqué deux fois il est
défendu deux fois pour le moment
sur kg 3 d'un v6 ou bep cap des
structures pointe
une vers la halle dames veerle droit
donc c'est logique que les blancs jouent
côté roy les noirs côté dames
ça peut transférer sans descendre ouais
ouais ouais ça peut transcender
espagnole avec le pion en russie ce
type d'espagnol assez
typique pittoresque
qui joue h3
ce qui peut jouer pour buffo à 6 pour
rentrer colonne s'est échangé le foot
case blanche
peut être une idée
c'est vraiment pour rentrer en cd avec
la dame qui fait ainsi
que scientifique du gambit marshall
damned
position vraiment difficile il ya
beaucoup de contacts de prise possible
et blanc peuvent vouloir jouer pour eux
5 mai savourer le fou bessette
que soe dominé ouais non mais c'est vrai
ça donne cette impression
truc c'est qu'il s'est fait avoir une
fois dans le dynamisme
diminuer aussi peut-être un
nom mais ces positions sont cool
aussi un petit problème de connexion on
sait qu'il ya plusieurs matchs cette
saison qui sont joués à l'aco ça peut
aussi être un petit peu inquiétant pour
lui
5 hockey
et la question c'est fou prend f3 d'un
prend pions prend puis on prend
cavaliers prend il veut quoi j'ai pas la
réf il veut fou pranger prend
si on prend pions prend un c'est pas con
ça
et après jouer pour watch deux tours
j'ai un f4 est attaqué
c'est pas bête
à
sans il pense qu'il peut avoir du jeu
avec les pions doublé devant le roi
comme il a un avantage des espaces il
craint pas pour la sécurité de son roi
il veut au contraire s'ouvrir la colonne
j'ai pour attaquer le roi noir
c'est très intéressant à vrai dire
donc il va pas vouloir élever ses quatre
alors il veut quoi il veut pousser 2 il
veut pousser deux fous prend qui
comprend qu'ils aient des cinq
maintenant pour taper sur ces 3 il veut
fou prend maintenant je pense à
intéressant le c4 qui enlève le sait
quoi trop blanc
très intéressant puisque dans l'autre
variante avec l'option ans et 5 il
aurait pu jouer c4 est chassé et du coup
ce que veut dire ou à thiès et que t'as
pas le temps d'organiser la taxe sur le
roi noir parce que t'es fixé sur ton
pioncer 3
ça joue vraiment au tempo ici hein
j'ai pas si vous avez l'aref
de ce tempo de plus de moins qui change
beaucoup de choses evènement peut-être
que les noirs peuvent vouloir jouer
baissé sur fou prend échanger remettre
l'autre cavaliers en d5 à
a g6 aussi intéressant il veut fou g7
tapez ici
pas se prendre un jour un f5 puis on
prend 1,6
qui pourrait faire extrêmement mal ils
apparaissent sûr que ça marche mais
jarris il faut le surveiller comme le
lait sur le feu le f 5,6
peut-être que j'ai ici c'était trop mou
au final
intéressant en tout cas cette position
cavaliers c5
donne le pion c4 quand même en un
mais il ya forcément une idée derrière
je pas sûr qu'il l'ait vu
j'ai l'impression qu'il a gaffé le pion
c4
parce que ça c'est un camp du tout
il a filé le pion en un
ça arrive quand on calcule trop de
variantes en fait deux surtout en rapide
en blitz
de finir par s'emmêler les pinceaux
angers cavalier e 4 tours b 8 c'est
logique
permettre le cavalier en d4 et il a
peut-être des tours points chauds aux
peut-être d'être en pointe froides à
mach 4 à regarder ça ça pue est ratée
par hikaru
quant à des coups comme ça un petit peu
surprenant comme tu en prends h4 dame
temps point je crois d'un match 4 tu
fais mais toujours un temps d'arrêt
parce que tu sais que ton adversaire l'a
raté c'est pas facile à voir et je me
demandais pourquoi est-ce qu'il a stop
là tout d'un coup sinon on voit cavale
et b4 tempo mais c'est vrai que ton
prochain je crois que l'on prend des
cinq d'un match 4 cavaliers j'ai trois
fous ces 5 fu ou trois tours prend pions
prendre d'un me prendrait fin ça donne
envie et oui c'était annoncé par le
streamer français hyper intéressant
c'était sûr que c'est quand tu fais un
temps d'arrêt c'est pour ton prochain 3
c'est pas un coup commun et c'est très
facilement raté par l'adversaire et
yappa cavalière six échecs intermédiaire
ya cavaliers prend important
écart vous l'a pas vu dans les carreaux
a raté
tout reprend un choix était ratée c4
était joué très vite et tout reproche je
crois est très complexe
si on prend d'un mach 4
et cavale et g3 c'est tout repoussé 5 fu
ou trois c'est la ligne et il doit avoir
tout reprend j'ai trois pions frangé
trois dames pranger trois roues en f1
tour b 3 il fait tomber trois comme ça
ok
injuste à noter que l'ordinateur donné
tour b3 avant comme égal et fous ces
cinq tours b 3 était une gaffe fallait
pas laisser dame f3 en fait
donc là hikaru maintenant est
complètement gagnant ces pièces de plus
et il ya plus de jeux
pour ses 3 c'est terminé il fallait
faire tourner b3 avant pour espérer
tenir l'égalité ouais ça c'est
complètement terminés ou sso qui rate
complètement son début de match
peut-être qu'on va
peut-être qu'on va assister à une petite
finale les amis la sicav vous prend 3,4
points la finale pour être terminée
après 25 minutes de jeu oh ça ferait
plaisir
ça ferait plaisir
là il n'y a plus rien
début très complexe il faut absolument
que l'on se reprenne
il n'y a pas le choix pour le chat
est sur la photo de profil il sort la
catalane et b3 à la variante de magnus
carlsson
cécile cau alors ça ça devait être la
partie d'ailleurs
inquiet prend des quatre
cavaliers à 3 donc ces petites positions
un petit peu pénible à jouer avec les
noirs parce que les blancs quand même
les deux fous sur les pions qui étend
dans les fientes eto'o qui tape et si
vous comparez les fous noir t'as pas
trop donc hikaru va réussir à se
débarrasser d'un fou mais va y avoir dû
cavaler ses cartes avait que quatre
tours d un car il est des six cavaliers
ou cinq qui va arriver et c'est un petit
peu pénible à jouer au noir alors c'est
rien de gravissime mais c'est pas
agréable quoi
les noirs sur fou prend b2 en réalité ou
s il veut jouer dame prend des deux
tours c'est un qui avait laissé quatre 4
cavaliers des six dames cet intéressant
touche un peu le cheval et s'enlève de
tous les problèmes menace x 3
bien joué de la part du carreau
l'acquis et qui passe à côté du début un
première partie ça feu dans une bonne
position il n'a pas poussé la deuxième
il s'est fait marcher dessus
et la troisième n'a pas été trop ça non
plus
il a une bonne position après il a moins
bien joué il m'a pas l'air d'être en
grande forme pour le moment
après le match est loin ça et beaucoup
de choses peuvent se passer
bon c'est toujours plus agréable pour
les blancs qui a valu au sein caduques
les français ici à la paire de fou qui
peut se présenter
il a mis ses lunettes à wesley et c'est
sûr que c'est bien de prendre l'avantagé
en début de match mais
est encore le temps
et encore même beaucoup de temps
aura du temps pour mettre des pubs aux
siens
la dre après j'ai vu un truc intéressant
c'est que ding a vraiment bien joué j'ai
faim j'ai peur j'espère pour lui mais je
pense qu'il peut être en grande forme
pour
pour les grands prix 1 j'ai l'impression
qu'il est vraiment bon ding
fourie sinko qui clique
bon
way to b 5 c'est vraiment cool comme
coup ça tape un peu de sa soeur de
cavale et prend ses six c'est vraiment
bien joué
bon début de match indikar ou solide sur
ses appuis sérieux le joueur américain
aulas il a
eu un changement de fenêtres
terrible
en fait je vois le le monitoring de la
fenêtre spéciale du car ou quoi mais en
un qui commence a déjà regardé des
meubles quoi terrible pro choix que ces
écarts ou qui regardait ses meubles
pouvoir il allait il est en train de
meubler son appart le frérot
c'est terrible
cruijff et al chez ea regarde et regarde
son ameublement quoi il est là il se
présente
ils pourraient prescrire ph à civaux
c'est terrible
kg quattro il veut simplement qu'il
prend m6 juste pour expliquer ou g5 il
refuse les échanges
damien il va faire dame b4 et les blancs
qui semblait mettre les noirs sous
pression vont vont devoir eux
l'encaissé
qui revient qui est b4 hockey menace
cavale et c2 maintenant
à
sur cavani ces quatre cavaliers c'est
dur à dams et trois tables g7
ça peut être cool ou au blanc ça ça ça
peut être très cool pour les blancs
ça peut être
sion
fo a trop
la rave pour ceux qui se demandent
on est pas évident
pavy position
fait cavaler f3 donc l'idée ses
cavaliers ces deux dames c'est 3-1
clairement
il faut m6 dame france et 2 ça c'est
facile
et surtout f6 vous prend et fissures a
pas d'âme premier fils à cause de dame
prend b4 important aussi
fort ici c'est maintenant cavalier des
quatre probablement
etc les blancs qui recommencent à
chasser les pièces adverse
il peut pas taper 17
il a un truc sur fou prend 17 mai j'ai
pas la réf pour b 8 fouet catch peux pas
vous répondre j'ai pas la réf
non il ya d'un premier set désolé pas vu
d' pas vu d' j'avais pas la réf
j'étais sur foot et sept de base et
c'est pour ça que j'ai oublié
et il couvrit
6,3 du coup ça c'est bien joué à eux
trois ils bloquent le fou c'est mieux au
blanc seing
c'est mieux au blanc
sur cinq a cavalé f5 ça c'est cool et
peut vouloir h4 au prochain vraiment
bloqué le fou et après faire du dames 2
adam ii va être fort ça va taper ici
mais en tête du g6
il ya du faux à trois qui peut traîner
ya du a3 ya beaucoup de choses pour les
blancs
g6 il anticipe est ce qu'il va faire à
trois qui a aidé 5 4
ça a eu quatre
cadets b 6 à 4
m
j'ai 7 5 à 4
voilà les noirs se font rouler dessus
bon il faut que west et réussissent à à
convaincre à conclure ici pour se
convaincre qu'il est capable de gagner
le match
s'il n'y arrive pas s'il n'arrive pas à
gagner celle-là ça va être ça va être
difficile à mon avis après il reste très
longtemps il reste encore trois heures
de match
même peut-être 3h30 on n'est pas sur les
cadences les plus rapides mais
psychologiquement c'est difficile
là il fait il fait une partie très
abouti pour le moment où wesley
c3 il veut cavaliers f 5 pions champions
prendra me prend g7 sur cavaliers f5 il
y avait qui prend 1,7 maintenant il ya
plus il va faire cavalier f3 dame e3
pour taper ici menace à 5 da me prends à
cette maintenant ça arrive de partout
ces six à cinq c'est quoi la réf
cavaliers 17 / d'un prince est il faut
prendre 4 allée wesley il faut faire le
taf
1 il a ainsi ce peut-être ici qui joue
sur la 7ème thema la taille
de la menace ya pas tomber vite on prend
des cette dame prend des huit cavaliers
ccico fois trois fois fuite un petit
tour un ici semble intéressant à mes
torts un fou prend soupe rampillon prend
dames 35 cm
c'est terrible cette défense d'hikaru
avec énormément de réussite
voilà la grosse réussite pour hikaru
mais c'est bien joué
ça aurait pu perdre ça pouvait perdre ça
en ligne mais ça n'a pas perdu
emma la taille de la défense
cassis était à deux doigts de gagner un
sale d'angelica rousset qui se sort
des griffes de ses adversaires
tel un chat
qui se baladent sur les sur sur le toit
et 3 d'un immeuble sur les gouttières
ça donne l'impression que ça passe pas
mais qui avoue passe toujours il passe
partout c'est un peu le kat von d échec
mondiaux
il se présente pas dans les tournois
amicaux il est vraiment très fort
leucate loin des échecs mondiaux
pourquoi pas il se faufile quoi
donc poussé sinko alors là c'est tout
bête hein les blancs les noirs veulent
cavaliers g4 d'un mach 4 d'un match de
maths c'est du coup franc est fou et 3
il supprime la pièce une des pièces
s'attaquant tfou des quatre
prises prises des 4
et sur ses 3 il veut juste pu comprendre
qu'il valait prend tourbe et huit étapes
et
basse là c'est rien c'est rien pour les
blancs oui c'est qui est sorti de la
sicilienne et c'est vrai que 4,5 me
donne de meilleures chances
donc tourbe et 8 on vient tapoter sur le
fou ici tour à trois et un coup de temps
en temps il y aura peut-être de la tour
qui revient sur la troisième mais
dangereux parce que la tour pourrait
aussi rester bloqué à vitam aeternam sur
cette case à troyes où elle ne fait rien
fo a deux maintenant foucher quattro qui
va partir
dams et deux tours b 4 peut-être et
d'anne decis
tombé huit ans come-back j'aurais joué
comme ça perso
j'aurais mis la tour en p4 je sais pas
si c'est une bonne idée mais j'aime bien
cette cage l'impression de taper sur
plein de trucs avec avec les noirs
il fait tomber quatre direct avant fou
g4
why not j'ai envie de dire
armand 7 tours en b quattro et bien ça
tape sur trois pions
aso est infligé quatre daims prend ainsi
j'avais tout reprend des deux camps même
séparés c'est cool
je pense d'ailleurs toujours floues g4
dame prend assistant prend b2 ça tape 1
ok
peut-être ça le gêne
j'ai pas pris g4 en fait je peux pas
vous expliquer ce que le couple paraît
logique
on menace si ces fugitifs je comprends
pas j'ai pas la rev 2 pourquoi pas fou
g4 en fait
on fout 17 est pas mal aussi intime
menace ou prend 1,4 quand même je vais
dit que cette tour en d4 était bien
alors là il veut fois quatre cavaliers à
quatre tours à 4 fev cette tour eiffe
cet enfant à quatre beaux pièges
d'enfoirés c'est bien joué joli coup
pour un
bien tour 1
et à 5 pour fixer
l activité supérieure au noir
dans sa clique un sa clique ça joue pas
mal en ce début de match quand même
je dois dire que
ouais ça a quand même été assez dominé
dans le jeu dans les derniers matchs
mais le truc c'est quand tactique il est
tellement au dessus
d'un meutre on doit pas avoir aux blancs
parce qu'ils apris prises et qui apprend
le 4
un tour b 8 qui vient pour moi augmenter
la pression sur le pion b2
on n'a probablement tour prend b2 ici à
peut-être y aura tout reprendre tout
reprend dame prend tour bien d'en
prendre de thorembais 8
pas de bol il
est fou c'est qu'a très bien joué de la
part d'hikaru à tourbes évite le coup
qui menace rien en fait et du coup on
n'a pas tout reprend b2 à cause de
l'enfilade à la fin et au prochain et la
b3 et consolident tout et c'est lui qui
va taper sur ses sept la partie en train
de tourner
je sais pas si vous voyez le moment
clutch là qui a eu dans cette partie le
fou ces cas de change tout parce qu'en
fait quand le fou en a deux souhaits v3
le fou et sean est donc là c'est gros
avantage noir le fou est complètement
bouché mais la même chose avec le fou en
ckd b3 c'est ultra solide et c'est ultra
fort celle inverse en fait
ouais
en tout
tombé huit sites et la fausse bonne idée
terrible
j'ai pas s'il faut pas faire flouer 6
vous prend dame prend mais histoire de
pas laissé se construire son truc
peut-être juste h6 et tu laisses faire
b3 et tu fait flouer 6
h il sera toujours utile il ya trop de
variants plus à des matchs du couloir
ça bug je crois pas un
ça peut être pas du tout ça réfléchit ça
calcule
ans maintenant ça veut pas ça aveugle il
avait raison
terrible en fait que ces bugs
ça bug ça bug
ça va beaucoup plus loin en fait ça à
jouer plus mais ça bug de beaucoup plus
loin donc il ya eu le fou aussi c'est
une des échanges
donc à faire voir cette 3d 6
qui veut créer des sites en france et 7
qui est tombé 5 ça doit aller pour les
noirs va la tenir quand même mais il
croit bien joué parce que ça aurait pu
être dangereux
ça les change
alors attention c'est pas complètement
mort comme position parce que les noirs
peuvent vouloir jouer sur le blocus sur
cases noires
sûr qu'ils allaient prendre ton tu en
prends tout reprend des six tours b 6
comment il fait nul en force
j'ai pas l'arrêt vous raté un truc sur
tourbe et si ce que tomber 6,17 3e set
pour des cas trois tours aussi salaires
avantages quand même weight enfants dès
6 3 6 3 et 6
chez bas salaires mieux pour les noirs
quand même bon j'avais jusque là et je
me demandais en réalité c'est surtout
réussi ce tour point 6.36 cedro et tous
rêvent 6-3 ici ton g63 h2 tapas es tu
peux
et tous réussissent puis surprend pions
prend roigé 3e 5 3g 4g
6h qu'à 3 f 7 h 5 contient ok c'est pas
clair que ce soit nul ça t'en ferons
aussi si on prend 1,6 est donc là c'est
mieux au noir g6 f5
ça c'est mieux au noir l'ordi donnent
également leur dit est complètement con
et blanc ont déconné j'ai passé il y
avait le simcoe créquy caroit raté en
fait je n'ai pas vu direct non plus et
je pense qu'il a dû rater de loin mon ça
ça reste nul
à wana il a laissé roi f4 maintenant et
très mal joué de la parade aux essais
il va pas du tout exercice pression en
fait
après quatre tours bekkat échec torrent
h4
ainsi si le redis été stupide c'était
quand même pression pour les noirs
il
à près de f5 à tour prend il va prendre
non
est ce un corps un tout petit peu mieux
au noir mais
je pense est très facile de faire
annuler esprit droit aux 5
bref c'est un croisé cet essai drôle
watch 6-3 et 6-3 prendre après un il n'a
pas réussi à exercer pression il n'était
pas loin puisqu'ils caro avait pas le
tour 6
et ils auraient pu mettre pressure as et
déjà la pause au bois la petite plus
petits par un ca fait plaisir
ah bah oui
ça fait plaisir une petite petit parrain
ça ça fait très plaisir
ah bah oui on va pouvoir souffler 1
suffit ou là
vers vers 22 heures
vers 22h pour le moment ça domine pour
hikaru mais ouais c'est dommage gens me
dire les deux points d'écart sont un
petit peu contre le cours du jeu
c'est un poil contre le cours du jeu
sans être incroyable non plus hein
j'espère que vous avez de la pub un qui
part
bon c'est bien je trouve cette petite
pause quand même ça fait plaisir ça
permet de souffler
match étant quand même assez rapide
globalement
st bo ou pas non c'est ans en nous
sentant c'est pas un nombre de points
s'informer un petit peu particulier
c'est un format un petit peu particulier
donc tu sais pas vraiment qui est
informée car en fait il fait vraiment
c'est magnifique il regarde les
audiences du truc et tout mais quel
génie cette sicav ou j'en peux plus quoi
les regarde le chat des cris de la mère
dans le chat je pense à ces magnifiques
il est dans le chat du truc twitch
quel génie hikaru quand même
henri viii sur le tchat
c'est magnifique
assez rare roger nuire
l'un des meilleurs sites français serait
tellement ça
il est vraiment très tranquille
un truc ce qu'il est beaucoup plus forts
en bulles est donc c'est vrai quand il
gère le match
dès la première séquence c'est cool pour
lui
ça le met quand même bien en confiance
plus facile ding ding ça se voit que
il s'entraîne pour être très fort pour
revenir à son niveau ça se sent on va
voir s'il y arrive ce sera difficile
mais
non il n'y a même pas fait le
il avait même pas tenté en fait encore
bon
voilà temps
deuxième partie du match
la france qui à perdre bâle
c'est terrible
attendre retour de wesley
mais je pars comme ils ont de pause en
tête 10 minutes
vous dire
ce que ça peut être rivaliser acquis car
en bullet
ouais on a bien vu que à la surprise
générale maxime avait été moins en moins
bon en bullet que fabiano donc tout est
possible alors qu'il était théoriquement
beaucoup plus fort
ouais complexe allez ça va re ça va
rejouer fête soit et cela n'arrive pas
vraiment à savoir les des timings
aller ça repart
il a changé il a joué b3 il a dit s'être
joué des cadres du coup assez et c'est
une imf zoo
j'imagine qu'ils ont dix minutes de
pause en réalité un
savions prend fou des trois
risques et deux m'ont tous les coups
sont très logique cède encore et
théoriques d'ailleurs
proposé dams et six dans le chat qui est
pas un super court
l'idée c'est que le cas il va protéger
le pion mais je crois que j'ai déjà vu
cette position quelque part
des trois ça anticipe les échanges des
pions ça prépare four b2
vous dire que ce au genou dans un
endroit tellement inconfortable
patients sa maison de vacances ou quoi
mais amel et sur un petit ordinateur
qui doit regarder vers le bas c'est
vraiment pas pratique son set up le sais
tape de sow est vraiment dégueu
un
le ça tapait vraiment dégueu pour
pour wesley
joue pas sur son tel mais je suis un
petit écran portable
sur un truc qu'il ya une très
inconfortable
ç'a vraiment pas l'air confort dont la
position du coup
ception isolé
pas qu'il soit au trackpad
voit qu'il ya une petite souris
on n'aimerait pas jouer depuis depuis
chez lui
il va faire froid f2 tour des deux tours
d un cavalier eux deux qui auraient des
f4 et prendre des cinq en gros c'est le
plan c'est assez durs à stopper avec les
noirs
2 c'est être mieux croit f2 ans a cédé
sont des choix
g3 faible si lecavalier bougerait mais
on va y arriver
peut d'ailleurs faire peut-être tour
c'est un ici
donc la 6e étape hardy chaise à larache
oui cette année dans le speech est cette
année l'année dernière il jouait pas
comme ça mais j'ai l'impression qui
prend les toits sur internet beaucoup
plus par dessus la jambe away s'est
dernièrement
f2 qui prendrait quatre reprend des
quatre ça paraît correct
il veut pas comprendre réussi je pense à
cause de pions prend qui renforcerait le
centre
hâtivement mon avis comme tour c'est
inquiets ces cinq des quatre qui reprend
des quatre fous prend des kataëb et
trois échecs
qui peut être pénible donc et b5 d'abord
je pense c'est bien joué
faut faire attention avec les north qui
est un rebond des six qui est pénible
c'est inquiétant il est peut-être en
train de se faire magouilles et
comment il va faire tour ces trois
tours c1 et b4
ouais c mieux ou blanc
c'est toujours mieux aux blancs même si
les difficultés techniques
racette une option mais je n'aurais
jamais osé
ces trois et hours thés un
élève à faire h3 tanger six tours 2
pour couvrir les pions
des trois-rois f2 tour d2 pour couvrir
tous les pions à l'est le roi
mais tours aussi si la cavalier c'est
cette
allée pour l'intérêt du match pourrait
coincer la gagne celle là à 4 des quatre
pieds b 3 20
ça a l'air d'être cool
en fait il vaut b4 kébé trois rois et un
des quatre cavaliers prend des quatre
pieds prend des captures en d4 de roy
prend à eux deux d'orange et de roy f1
et tour c'est 8 à la fin et un cavalier
fuite
c'est ça son idée sais pas si vous avez
vu mais en gros quand échanges tout à la
fin il ya pas match
mais
4 il a peut-être tour des 3
et le pion sera cloué l'aura qu'elle
prendrait ses tours des trois ans fait
qu' on prend marche pas et ça c'est ce
qu'a fait hikaru c'est la variante
humaine
et à la fin il ya cavaliers fuite
mais tour des 3 l'art de faire mal
ce que cavalli 4 comprend des quatre
fous prend des quatre c'est quasiment
imparable
ouais ça il a raté car outre et c'est
très très clairement un petit geste de
la tête il n'avait pas le tour des trois
et tour des trois cavaliers 5 et puis on
prend des quatre qui les prend avec
trois tours à huit matches
il n'avait pas tourné 3
je vous ai dit un cetc du commentaire
qualitatif attention et maintenant c'est
fou prend des quatre pieds prend des
quatre je sais pas moi j'aurais pris du
cheval hacker prend des quatre pieds tu
dois prendre du fou fou prend et
maintenant ses pions de plus
mes poupées deux come back ils bloquent
toutes les infos b2 qui a valu aux cinq
ans est marlou faut prendre cinq tours
sermat
à mes poupées deux cas valeo 5 tours
prend b3 puis on prend fou prend 1 5
tours g5 f4 et l'a pas le temps de m6
dont qui la fout
b2i la foulée eux c'est jouer et y
appelait cavaliers cinq tours prend b3
way
amea peut-être tour des huîtres le coude
en foire et alentours des 3 est un
cavalier des trois tours en d3 donc il
ya peut-être fait retour des 8 3 en
moins cavalière trois pions prend pions
prend b3
c'est sûrement la ligne non il fait ça
comme ça et s'en prend aux cinq tours c6
est fou b2 come back à four b2 tour
c2b deux tours ces deux
cavaliers des cathos prend au droit
prend 2 finit tôt allez voici qui
revient
et c'est le tour des trois qui a
vraiment clutch
ouais ouais c'est le truc qui cloche à
l'éval de calan tahri est pas un mauvais
web parce qu'en fait en somme on joue
assez bien les derniers jours comme j'ai
dit je suis assez en forme je suis bien
reposé donc du coup je calcule à ma
vitesse normale et ça fait que je peux
voir deux trois trucs
à l'est
croche à 5 on retourne dans la game
sur un site et la game numéro 3 ou 5 du
match
pour ses huîtres ou des 3b catway c'est
exactement le ce truc là et caro avait
joué le simcoe alors je sais pas si tu
es ici ou un peu plus loin il a
peut-être commencé par dame 2
il change complètement fou g-sync au
jeu si ce fou 3
et là peut-être des cinq est possible de
5 carats lieu 4 ça ça peut être des
idées pour à faire briller le fou
fois fuite hockey
town d2
voilà tout cas là on se posait la
question est ce que pions prend pions
prend avec des idées de prises prisé
fois ci c'était intéressant ou pas on
sait par la même position mais l'idée
c'est de jouer sur la colonne c'est et
d'éventuellement rentrée en c2
clairement plus vous prend assistant
points à 6/8 pourra doubler colonnes b
le match est serré parce qu'ils caffin
ouest il a bien réussi à serrer quand
même la vis ça partait mal mais je le
sens légèrement au dessus dans le jeu et
il est pas moins bien autant hikaru qui
domine pas au haut niveau de la vitesse
de jeu et d'exécution
donc ça peut ça peut être intéressant ça
sur le moyen terme pour pour wesley
qui pourraient dominateur
reste avançant de noir n est pas mal de
choses à mon sens benoît
mais oui cette idée de fois ci c'était
été proposé un peu plus tôt mais c'était
difficile de juger
dame b
pas trop il ya tourbe et un peut-être
dame c6 ou tour b6 aussi tour à 8,1 peut
être une idée pour se replacer de
manière plus standard
car oui car au moins angoissé qui
hésitent ici
est ce que ces 4,5 et une option je
pense pas ça donne à 15h sinko tour à 8
soit assez standard
aman complexe la cavale et des deux
les blancs ont le centre mais les noirs
peuvent peuvent pénétrer
sur les cases
je serais tenté de rentrer ans et
220 8 un coup de temporisation qui est
pas mauvais
auxquels il peut vouloir du tour b de
danse orange il peut vouloir du pion
prendre un de ses deux tours b 2
c'est très difficile de s'y retrouver de
accueilli ces 4
s'est qualifié 4 l'idée alors il a peu à
cavalli c4i la tour prend 1 2 puis on
prend des quatre dames français quatre
rôles à la tma la taille de long x ray
c'est bien joué du coup tombée deux très
forts hikaru qu'ils n'avaient pas assez
hikaru qui se fait prendre dans le petit
jeu taxi car on le voit tout de suite à
la cam quand on regarde qui avait laissé
quatre ans et depuis on prend des katas
me france et 4 ces méchants
ont prises prise dame devrait
thema la taille du problème à mais
peut-être damev uno avec qui des tours
font à deux tours c'est ou non et en
france et 8 ça défend encore il ya
quelques barbelés de me côté car vous
mesdames f1 il va faire damas quatre et
tour ces deux
là il faut mettre les barbelés r il faut
c foot thierry met une série de barbelés
dans le chat si thierry mais pas les
barbelés là ça va pas tenir terrible
pour thierry
thierry doivent une petite c'est un
petit mur de barbelés à lui tout seul
tort c'est 3 il veut tout reprend à
dame prend à 5 33 tours prend 3 la dame
protège donc dame 3,5 y votre choix il
veut des cinq tours à trois os est
méchant c'est méchant côté wesley quand
il est rentré dans le match là wesley
et en plus tu auras 3 ce sera dam des
huit tombes évitant fermement ces
terribles au hikaru qui prend la marée
là quand même rester qui a serré la vis
il a serré le jeu là wesley il joue vite
en plus
il a complètement relancé le match
assure les 2/3 dernière game il fait mal
pour ces trois fait très mal tour ces
trois dames prend 1,5 des cinq ça donne
pas envie
j'ai l'impression qu'il a vu quelque
chose il a une mimique
wesley il a vu quelque chose pour hikaru
après dessins qu'il ya un truc que j'ai
dû rater
j'ai pas la réf en fait
série mais pas les barbelés
or il est pas bien en tyrie si tu mets
pas de barbelés ça va pas le faire
il va
or à 3 est-ce que je vais quatre
champions du monde de rapides et blitz
ouais mais je vais les casses moi perso
sur ma chaîne j'aurais pas les calmes
dessine qu il veut à 3 j'imagine
ce que dessine comme nasri ou b 4 aussi
tout reprend 1,3 fou prend des deux
éventuellement
je pense dessine cora
30 en trois dames prendre des deux il ya
encore dame prend des deux tours plombé
de merde c'est moi qui rate un mais il
veut à 4 après dans tous les cas ça
passe pas mes dessins que salaires y
performent
dans tous les cas des cinq à trois
peut-être tout reprend prise prise prise
prises et ça va
des cinq ça al'air tellement fort
donc c'est un peu impression prisséen
est peut-être tombé 1 qui a valu à eux
quatre et on tape non ça a l'air hyper
fort
ce qui est étonnant
leucate reprise prises qui épaississent
qui a aidé 5 mai doit avoir une idée
hikaru
salaire dit que mais
il veut cavaliers 4 qui est pris en 4
comprend dame c6 attaqué dame prend 1,4
pour ça qu'il fait tour à 3 en premier
et sur dame cécile peut-être tour à 6
23 la partie est vraiment compliqué et
difficile à et dames cécile cavale et
baies vitrées et 17
hockey mais il faut que tu la joues à
cela mais la 34 secondes or il va
prendre la drôme à le pleutre
hacker cavaliere at il ajou
qu'avait db6 qui a laissé 4 c'est quand
même gros avantage
cavaler b8 non je pensais que ces cas et
b 8 son idée
je veux quoi il veut cavaliers g5
maintenant tour à 6 ha oui bon ok il va
organiser qui a et b 6 quai c4 est le
cas il va revenir en d2 attention c'est
une partie très importante dans le match
qui a aidé deux poupées quatre dames ses
huit cavaliers fuite est fou prend
cavaliers c4
à l'est pour le suspense faut quoi sert
il à chercher celle là
il a pas eu de beaux lui sur salat
wesley ça aurait pu être gagnant icaro
qui a très bien défendu quand même comme
d'habitude solides en défense à l'écart
va laisser quattro j'ai pas compris le
coup d'avancé si cela même si tours à
huit dames 17 tours à deux peut-être
rentrer sur les cases
excès de pleutres itude il faut arrêter
d'être plus haute la faut cliquer un
tour à 2mb cinq tours est ok tourbe et 8
c'est bien c'est un joli clic
cavaliers d2 il veut quoi sur kid à
cavalli et et de tourbe et six dames 8
il enferme pas pour le moment
h41 les tours à deux il faut rentrer là
dans la position
c'est chose faite h4 c'est pour bloquer
le cavalier sur la case interdire kg 5
mais d'un autre côté le cavalier un
rebond intéressant et fuite le cavalier
f1 est immobilisé la tour va arriver en
b2
et le temps commence à être intéressant
allait tomber de faut cliquer pourquoi
cette tour j'ai pas la réf j'aurais mis
l'autre pour rentrer à s'équiperont de 3
est rentrée dans la pause
peut-être tour ces deux noms harry
il a peur
c'était faire ça
c'est pas des mauvais coups mais ils
jouent avec il joue avec le frein à main
il joue avec le frein à main alors c'est
solide évidemment un côté wesley
aller il continue à être bien quand même
ils contrôlent toutes les cases blanches
avec les pions les quinze ans avec le
fou
quand ils racaille praxis et chacun
rende c'est n'importe quoi mais c'est
n'importe quoi
c'est pas possible
t'as pas le droit de rater ce en un t'as
pas le droit at a pas le droit à bordel
mais non ne sais mais c'est n'importe
quoi il rate une pièce en un
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus de lui
non le problème c'est qu'ils jouent
trois quatre coups au lieu de jouer les
coups vers l'avant ils jouent des coudes
pour on ne sait pas s'ils jouent pour
faire nul ou pagaille
tarbes n'a pas envie de gagner une
partie de te présenter un petit peu t'as
pas envie d'aller la chercher et là ils
jouent après pakistanaise hikaru
assez fou dessine co qui avait cassé ce
que j'ai joué hier fou des cinq dames c3
et la cecafa lieu qu'à tous ses cinq
direct et peut-être dam des trois plus
malin
t'as pas envie un petit peu de jouer des
coups vers l'avant la tourbe et deux
tours c'est de rentrer
ne ressemble un petit peu à quelque
chose
mais c'est fait il va perdre le match
sur des trucs comme ça c'est pas
possible
il connaît pas théorie avec les blancs
dans cette variante il n'a pas le cahier
il n'a pas le grimoire wesley assez
terrible là il va pas être bien
cette variante elle est hyper relou aux
blancs
pas de slip
pas de stress ya le s ils ne jouent que
pour les nuls
non mais y en a marre quoi on peut assez
des parties clutch fallait absolument
qu'il a gagné et pas faire nul et il
appert quoi sur une pièce qui file en un
coup quoi une pièce en un
on se marre seront ce soir section mais
on se marre pas du tout ruth tu as vu ce
qu'il vient de faire
n'importe quoi ce qui nous fait wesley
alela benga belga il faut un peu serré
le jeu
n'a pas envie de jouer deux couverts la
vente a pas envie
non me rend fou les frérots il rend fou
et cela
ils regardent la y réfléchit encore à sa
partie de merde là qui vient de faire il
ya trois minutes c'est terrible
c'est terrible pour y regarde tous ont
ouvert la gauche prix regarde tous au
même endroit
s'envoyer inquiéter carlson à l'époque
et à palmer qui le voyaient quitter car
celle j'avais vu ou assez s'inquiéter
car la scène
bon là
serrer le jeu allait tapions plus il
faut y aller wesley
c'est pour l'intérêt du match après 1
que soit on reste coi carrosse à peu
près pareil soit l'un ou l'autre qui
gagne pour nous ça change pas grand
chose même si on aimerait bien que ce
soit et ce l'est on va pas se le cacher
on ne va pas se le cacher
si vous allez rapidement elle est très
bon
mais hier que ces deux joueurs terrible
montrant
le salon est que ce gagne c'est que le
budget sont remplacés par 1960 rabat là
il serait favori aux mêmes
normes et là il joue mieux en fait c'est
arina ricard où il est vraiment
monstrueux
temmar la taille des barbelés qui mary
siens
car on représente which mis au fait de
quoi ils preuve en twittant fait
hikaru représente which
représente which
genre tu voyais karoubi a été
représentant de switch
en plus un pour wesley
n'obligez pas l'arrêt fait représente
twitch
en ce pays quand ils sont passés non si
t'as jamais été champion du monde tu
peux pas être le meilleur face à heist
pas en fait
bon ses pions de plus en tout cas je
sais pas il ya il a bien joué là bas
c'est aller il faut jouer des coups vers
l'avant
ensuite il retourne tout le monde n'a
jamais gagné un championnat du monde en
fait
on s'est quand même complexe de détruire
tout le monde quand t'as jamais gagner
ta vie quoi enfin
magnus retourne tout le monde oui
je confirme
mes hikaru
c'est un excellent joueur mais
ne va pas la gagner une nouvelle fois au
vestiaire
il représente un peu les échecs sur
twitter autoproclamé un
travailleur
ok
cavalier
de plus mais c'est tellement dur à
pousser
en bis avec magnus parent enfin un ennui
c'est plus fort enfin je sais pas c'est
quand même chose de pas comprendre que
magnus est plus fort
pour toi il ya bien du monde 2 et plus
représentent que les lots ah bon en
blitz et rapide où il le vélo vaut rien
on glisse et rapide le calcul du hello
est tellement mal foutu que
oui clairement c'est les titres envie de
sang rapide
et pas du tout le vélo il ya quasiment
pas de tournoi et le calcul est
tellement tronquée
comme c'est pas un calcul parti après la
partie tu peux gagner 200 300 points
l'eau sur un tournoi c'est n'importe
quoi
on présente à quel point m a glissé
meilleur je suis pas dix mille fois
meilleur cent mille fois je sais pas
car le vice-champion du monde empli de
sauter par en titre oui bah c'est pas le
meilleur je racontais deuxième n'est pas
le meilleur
et un tape plein de joueurs actuels qui
ont été champions du monde de blitz
magnus
ou de rapides ta magnus stade ou bof tu
as a great chioukh takhar yakine ta
ivantchouk il y en a quand même beaucoup
qui ont gagné great soul trois fois
c'est comme ça
et là ça va être drôle encore
je pense
il n'ya pas c'est incroyable qu'il n'ya
rien
5,3 g 6/4 et dfk 3g cette
série que magnus à plus 50 cent de
chances de gagner le championnat du
monde de billes ça dépend qui joue avec
la liste actuelle il a pas mal de chance
s'ils manquent quand même alireza par
exemple
j'ai pas s'il participera mais bon à
vrai dire je pense qu'elle s'emballe
avec les raisins
je pense qu ali reza pour lui l'intérêt
c'est d'être champion du monde point
barre je pense qu'il a un objectif et il
est clair
c'est quoi la sur qui est pro f 6 dames
g5 roger cette cavale et h5 ya pas un
matelas quelque part
j'essaie de quel âge 5 ça gagne et c'est
le poteau pour wesley il suffisait
d'arrêter de regarder
j'ai pas trop compris ce qui serait
lancée en fait c'était bien pour les
blancs juste le voyais pas terminée
et qu'il s'agit d'un format local magnus
n'est pas meilleur non ça n'existe pas
960 en fait en 966 ouest les meilleurs
mais sinon
pourquoi les résas fait pas les mondiaux
de blitz eux j'en sais rien pour le
moment il n'est pas annoncé mais
peut-être qui s'emballait complètement
comme je disais alireza lui ses
objectifs ils sont clairs nets et précis
ces deux c'est de gagner les candidats
et devenir champion du monde et
peut-être qu'il a des sessions
d'entraînement et qui veut pas perdre
son temps avec ça ou peut-être qu'il ira
les jouets ou peut-être qu'il a du mal à
avoir un visa mais en quoi que ya pas de
visa sans pologne finalement il pas au
kazakhstan tel qu'il a prévu autre chose
hein
sur puis on prend b4 vrai bon je pensais
à prendre b4
son froid
si on
ici ça 5 x 6
x 5 x 6 vite pour jouer dams et 2 en
tout cas ils s'accrochent restait quand
même
c'est vrai qu'à la partie là qui doit
gagner qui perd elle fait mal parce
qu'il pourrait mener quatre et demi
trois et demi fait il est mené au score
contre le cours du jeu wesley mais bon
il carbure joue sur ses points forts
et donc
2faire fois ci c'est un peu ça le
problème
bon
prix
à peut-être un dessin qui a valu au 4
mai c'est dur de dire si ça passe kg cas
d'accord mais un
truc c'est que cavani va un peu dans le
désert quoi
il apparaît de points d'accord je vais
il veut
sur la shoah il veut quoi d'ailleurs
cavaliers affichent is fuoh 3g pas la
réf webb a d'ailleurs
peut-être sympa ce que x 6 des 5 fu
prend prise je vois pas ce que ça
en fait c'est gagner un tempo avec
cavaliers g4 fait-il ap il a rajouté
d'un bébé si ça je crois dans la
position c'est assez bien joué en fait
c'est comme si ici sur dame v6 il avait
forcé h3 et x 6 et grâce à cavani j4
cavani m6 il a transposé là dedans c'est
très bien joué de la part de wesley
et maintenant vous prend des 3es damas
six
a pas d'âme à 6 alors d'un b5 peut-être
pour da mcadams et quatre
voiliers qui jouent vraiment bien ses
positions est là il a été très très bon
joué de la part de west et ça lui a
permis d'obtenir la position enfin comme
si sûr d'imbéciles forçage 3 c'était
très malin
et pas tour c'est donnant surtout ces
deux il y avait deux français deux
dames bassinko
et maintenant il veut tour ses sept
tours ces huit en fait bêtement
et jouer la colonne c'est ok c'est
intéressant
je sais bien qu'il ya je crois main
c'est pas forcément bien mais en fait
cavalier j'ai quatre cavaliers fils ça
lui a coûté deux coups et les blancs ont
fait food et de foudroyage 3 ça leur a
coûté trois coups donc c'est comme s'il
avait inclus h3 en fait
pris ce qu'avait lieu 4 x 4 ok
et maintenant il va faire cavalier b6 il
va laisser le cavalier en prison le 4 il
va rejouer le
les cases comme dans la partie 1 du
match pour ce qu'ils ont vu
il fait qu'il ait projet 3
aussi possible
ayvaz 4 à 3 et fixé le pion à deux ça
son plein en fait
j'imagine
koné de position de départ au chef 960
la réponse est contenue dans la question
vous prend cavaliers prend h six
cavaliers f3 non ils échangent pas et
garde le fou
ouais c'est bien joué puisque le fou
obstrue cavaliers g5
non c'est un peu une course là les tours
vont pouvoir couvrir f7 mais c'est quand
même assez dangereux
dame c4
alors attention tonk lecavalier n'a pas
bougé n'ya pas tour à cet oued à me
prend à deux
ça paraît très dangereux dame prend à
deux
tours f3 et on prend un essai tout en f3
j'imagine qu'il va jouer un coup de
cheval en b 8 pour repartir vers ces 6es
avoir tour à cet ours et 7 pour couvrir
un
gym jean
sur ces 7 d'abord
pour f3 qui a et b 8 ça c'est sûr
ouais
bien joué il veut cavaliers c6 qui
apprend des quatre mêmes sur dame prend
des captures à des fous ces cinq prises
prise damas six c'était sûr aussi la
dudh à main en plus ce qui est pénible
et qui va lier ces six
feux trois courts mesdames 1 quand même
je pense que sans les dames la position
doit être cool to race est
pas un mauvais coup clairement
mesdames un pareil c'est tellement cool
pour échanger
et tour ces 3
way sli
ah
ok bah géométrie mais sa tour va être
super mal passé
car il est choquant fait la tour est
dégueulasse angers 6 elle va se faire
enfermer
à ces terribles
contresens
terrible ça c'est la fatigue ouest et
sow qui pioche
à la il a pioché là
est dans le dur physiquement ou wesley
ça c'est faute de concentration que tour
ces trois tours tours pranger 3 pour
gagner le pion c'est eux c'est un petit
contresens là qu'il a fait c'était très
original c'était difficile à voir et
c'était bien vu mais ces contresens
et maintenance à tour est tellement mal
c'est terrible elle participe plus au
jeu
complètement annihilée par par toutes
les pièces blanches
away compris
perdu mais clairement avec dame 1 il
avait une position sans risque et
peut-être avantages et là c'est lui qui
est sous le sous le feu un el fuego el
fuego d'approuver alors american au
stadio dino ce
carreau nakamura
d'amin tout à l'heure il y avait la main
est là il ya plus mais tout alors il y
avait il y avait un cavalier en juin
il va devoir repartir avec le fou
ce qu'ils aiment menace maintenant de
gagner le pion et si tu prends prend et
à la casa quattro qui est pénible parce
qu'il ya du cavalier qui arrive
ça sent que c'est du contresens
allées du reims à l'aller très dur dans
la tête allez c'est là qu'il faut clutch
c'est peut-être la dernière partie du
cinq plus un elle est hyper important de
celles-là parti compte double
alors attention parce qu'il peut tout
prendre en g5 et après prise prise prise
il ya foule ou trois ans come back pour
taper la
hausse a l'air bien joué tour c'est un
os à une tête de très bons coups ç'a de
la part du carreau
il sent l'odeur du sang le joueur
américain
c'est bien joué peut-être faute hourra
trois cavaliers à 7 pour cover
peut-être tour à 3 pour attaquer la
troisième rangée tour c'est cette
tension il se met dans un clouage
prisse prise dame ces deux il va faire
tour c ur et non ça va pas là pour
wesley
dams et 5 d'un bessette
la dame rentrée des
6es oui là il est en train de se faire
retourner
il échange qui a eu 7 mai la finale elle
est horrible la tour qui va venir se
décaler manger le pion époux c'est
terrible la tour angers 6,5 qui va
perdre la partie elle toute seule
très bien joué de la part
dit caro
attention il laisse le pion
b&o attention ça c'est en train de
retourner
alors que la séquence est finie
cavaliers f4 alors heureusement pour
hikaru turaci ce qui va les prendre à
nauroy proyas tout reproche trois la fin
aux îles à il est en train de la tournée
hikaru qui sut aux issues y pense savoir
qu'ils avaient les g5 un g6 hikaru qui
va envoyer h quatre cavaliers
hoya packard et léger si ces cavaliers
g5 matt
cavale et g5 et prosys maintenant
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de hikaru et c'est complètement gagnant
incroyable passe d'armes entre les deux
hommes est maintenant au 6e 7e 8 il
narré table ça s'est joué à rien
ça s'est joué à rien
et il va ya maintenant une petite pause
à ça s'est joué à rien du tout là
ça s'est joué à rien du tout mais wesley
qui s'est complètement trompé avec sa
tour à tour ces trois tours pranger 3
c'était vraiment du contresens je pense
qu'un coup comme damas était vraiment
cool
en espérant échanger
et jouer sur les colonnes ouverte y
avait aucun risque en fait
non il s'est hissé contre sens joli
match en tout cas pour le moment assez
serré mais hikaru hikaru halid trois
minutes de pub bien évidemment ça fait
plaisir
mais je comprends pas c'est pour
échanger les dames quoi jouer les
colonnes
mais autour pranger trois tours j'ai si
c'était vraiment du contresens
bhl
à l'étranger 3 c'était une mauvaise
décision après on a un peu dans
l'irrationnel 1
on était un peu dans l'irrationnel
c'est un peut cliquer ouais c'est un peu
un peu trompe ados quoi
il s'est un peu trompé de hikaru ça
arrive hein
ça arrive arrive aide
mais ça arrive de temps en temps
de se tromper c'est dur de passeront
paix mais le truc c'est que ouais ils
dominent dans le milieu de jeu ils
dominent dans le jeu
qui fait de la merde
100 m
à l'école anne on s assoit bons fous
plus colonnes plus structure mais juste
les dames avec un peu d' attaque sur le
roi ça sent que c'est relou
caro qui jeu
qui joue mieux qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on y fasse comme ça
faire les noms et bandeau jaune
j'ai envie de te dire peut-être mais ce
n'était pas fait pour
car web je vais faire un montage photo
avec i cry câbles ont ils cabré un écart
ou les trois i khas
bon jeu pas pour qu'on l'a pas fait
ycare om malik arous c'est plutôt hikaru
qui gagne c'est un mauvais match up pour
maxime
ces quelques inventions c'est une heure
de 3 + 1
magnifique
c'est ogec ou qu'ils gagnent en vie dure
à dire très dures à dia mety karoubi
chirugien il a un peu quit le truc mais
ils ont je pense que firent ou déjà
hâlées où seraient devenus déjà plus
fort
karine auspices la semaine précédente
hikaru
blanc
sous domine pas ce soir mais après cette
année j'ai l'impression que c'est
globalement ça passe super bien joué
quand tu vois ni à l'an 2000
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya aucun gros
joueurs mise à part hikaru qui a aidé
inc peut-être était la finale avant
l'heure qui ont vraiment joué les vingt
à cent pour cent
mais digne réputé pas très fort
normalement sur internet je crois que
c'est les deux seules à avoir vraiment
jouer à 100%
bio au niveau où je veux dire
ni à 3150 sur chaise comment ils
d'accord mais bon c'est pas un joueur du
top niveau
il pourrait être quatre mille civils et
sur chaise comme c'est pas un joueur de
haut niveau
tu parce qu'il fait s il répare
longtemps
donc ils se sortent de haut niveau à une
patrouille carreaux fera qu leur non non
il faudra que tu leur demandes
si sa clique
by karl notre cas ce qu'on attend mais
la raison en fait c'est long c'est une
ration succédant sanctions n'ont pas du
tout sa date d'avant qui karoui n'est
pas très bien vu par par les autres
joueurs mais ça il faut demander aux
gens concernés
il faut demander aux gens concernés
k
après west et qui est une mauvaise
connexion ça peut aussi bien sur un flux
et de barres
sûr que ça pue un tout petit peu joué
donc je
m'étais porte ward chasse comme 2021 où
j'ai même pas que ça avait lieu monsieur
p soit
déjà perdu 10 secondes au début m après
les deux bars secte ait décoré
aucun cas où qui joue agressif
ah ouais petit rat qui veut h 4 juste
il va vouloir jouer avec h4
en dames sain il temporise et il veut
faty veut un peu passé son tour et se
dire que si les noirs font petit rock
petit rock le courage 5 sera un peu
superflu
de foix iii aussi ouais mais je pense
qu'il veut surtout temporisé par ok trop
vite
et prend kg qui fâchent cathy là quand
même il prend vite peur quand même
wesley
5 à l'effort maintenant faut pas avoir
trop peur trop longtemps
déjà manquantes a trop peur trop
longtemps ça se retourne contre toi
maintenant faut vraiment rockets et tant
pis c'est pas grave g5y lacaille points
4 qui est rangée 5 et il le fera qu il
éprouve 4 kg cinq plus tard
et petit
ce qui est quand même apprécié de la
communauté moi j'apprécie c'est stream
perso hikaru
après tout tous les biffer des trucs
comme ça avec les autres joueurs de haut
niveau
c'est une autre histoire
et pranger traînez pas vraiment je crois
qu'il ya juste lui ont présenté un pion
de
3,6 kg 5 way
x 3 m position des blancs c'est à jamais
de d'ouverture du roi on va pouvoir
prendre faire damas trois à surtout
reprendre peut-être des quatre et même
si le cas les arrivants g4 en fait je
vois pas de problème à 5 j'aime bien sûr
b5 on va avoir de la casse ces 5
c'est ça
il veut échanger les chevaux
et jouer j'ai 5 h 4
c'est étonnant mais c'est très bien joué
tout reprend c'est pas mal parce qu'en
fait si on prend tout reprendre aussi
surtout reif 8
qui est un échec à ces salles avec la
dame qui protège la tour
et si les noirs sont croqués pas obligé
mais si tu prends pas en passant ça va
être des quatre et ça va être chiant
il prend pas son tour prend ça c'est sûr
et j'ai cinq tours f1 c'est sûr aussi à
mon avis voilà je comprends j'aime pas
toile f1 team et c'est un peu touré
fuite quand même
hein
il a dû rater pour effet de pousser 8 x
h trois dames g3
wave est en train de comprendre les
variantes qu'il a vu et pourquoi c'était
bien ce qu'il a fait
j'avais raté un truc mais c'est trop
long à expliquer donc tour des huit neuf
ou peut-être un touret fuite
et toi fuite d'un prendre trois rouages
deux dames g5 come back to reprend des
huit dames prend des huit tours f8 foule
adam donc en fait on menace a donc les
noirs vont sûrement joué tour à chaud
suite
et prisa je suis de prisa chu de tours
fc est donc il ya peut-être faire tour
17 mais tours d'essai tour des huit
tours fc est
ok tours fc est directe servier en même
temps point f cette dame prend pour
preuve sa taille adam pranger trois
problèmes
bible
terrible raté et le truc c'est que rld à
manger trop salé trop forte elle défend
et attaque donc sa seule chance et
d'aller chercher une dhr au
hockey de dame prend fou prend double
attaque c'est bien joué dans me1 roi jeu
de dames hk 3g un
fou au cices ça va être la ligne puisque
la dame en h4 des champions
il faut aussi ça va être la ligne
ouais c'était sûr
maintenant il veut quoi
damev huit dames c5 ça va pas aller
j'ai l'impression que c'est complètement
foutue aux blancs
tête d'un f4
pour d'un prof puis on prend un f4 des 4
et le pion de plus c'est superflu ça
peut être une idée
et la dame f4 je pense
[Musique]
fait contourner terrible et la dame qui
va venir en d6 avec h3
gagne ados savent a gagné
assez facilement fait
bien jouer hikaru
ça arrive des deux et
le roi et réseauter
et roger rage de roy prend âge de
fouiller 4
ça creuse
ça creuse l'écart côté hikaru
je n'ai pas vu un seul en faveur d'un k
-o wesley a pas été tant d un problème
avec les caméras ça devrait revenir
il n'a pas été fou
dans les autres dans les autres matches
à vrai dire ça sent un peu qu'ils
qui prend un peu moins ces compétitions
sur internet au sérieux qu'avant
donc
perso ça m'étonne pas en fait
rendez 6
il va y avoir problème
y avoir un fou proches cette reprise
absents qu'il a raté quelque chose
ding a failli gagner à way
bing a failli gagner contre hikaru et
non mais ça sent que
parce qu'il a raté en fait
caire
ces quatre
fois j'ai l'impression qu'il a pensé
raté un truc wesley en fait non
elle prend 5 tours des huit têtes
non il est pas bien où cela coup de mou
après la partie pas très intéressante
ça pourrait être match fini assez
rapidement en fait
on va essayer qui accueille retenu un
certain moment
qui sait pas récompensés peu comme au
rugby en fait c'est pas récompensé en
prenant les points les points
valent à faire l'accent du sud-ouest et
du coup maintenant il est puni
les pluies les a pas pris et les punir
il faut se récompenser en fait quand tu
domines et là il l'a pas fait
c'est juste deux pions de moins et il ya
air en vrai
il à gages les munitions est
hélas moins quatre ça va semblait déjà
très difficile
safina non ça joue jusqu'au bourg à
turin
c'est terrible comme que depuis quatre
ans depuis cinq éditions ils ont
toujours pas compris qu'un format cet
été plus drôle enfin on va pas revenir
là dessus une énième fois mais c'est fou
hamelin
ces cinq et damman et bon
allez il faut qu'il réussisse à tenir
celle là reste à trois points et gagner
la prochaine
dur
pour le mans c'est dur de mettre la
marche avant pour les blancs le pion à
qui elles qui ont passé peut pas avancer
le pion c'est non plus
donc il ya quelques petits problèmes de
l'organisation
les blocs bien la wes les fêtes il a des
bonnes séquences en défense mais c'est
ils n'arrivent pas à tuer les parties à
son problème
va finir par réussir à le croquer le
pion
maintenant d'ailleurs
ça va faire pion de moins mais le pion
c'est commencent à mettre la marche
avant
donc c'est que jouer contre nous c'est
un peu joué contre comme un peu comme
jeu contre rafa quoi tu as l'impression
que ça va
mais le problème c'est qu'à force il te
fatigues quoi
allez plus que 15 secondes pour icare où
il faut mettre quelques barbelés tout
réfuté seul coup ici tu comprends pions
francs et défendre la finale des dames à
l'est puis on prend qui on prend tout
reprend droit prend il faut la défendre
celle là
mais ouais là où il a un petit portable
hikaru c'est qui va te la jouer pendant
des plombes il va forcément réussir à
échanger les dames c'est terrible
c'est vraiment terrible
truc ces cas les doigts je sais pas si
elle est gagnante ou pas mais pense
réussir à la gagner
ouais c'est dur c'est dur parce que
il tient toutes les cases mais il va y
avoir des piéjos il va finir par s'en
prendre à après il a bien mis sa dame en
a deux ils couvrent il peut même partir
en g8 avec le roi à vrai dire en cas de
pépin
à l'êta maïté
avec
elle a peut-être un damas signe qu ici
dans mes frais c'est bien joué aussi
mais il va faire d'un des huit d'un
match 4 à isle adam d1 dames des quatre
allées bien jouer wesley
sa faiblesse parce que sa relance le
match
et dames f6 bientôt il peut peut-être
même la gagne et non quand même pas
c'était pas loin de se présenter
en défense il est bien où là attention
quand même
le roi un peu bizarre ouais c'est bien
défendu
eyeka rookie il a plus de coup il a
quasiment plus de coups hikaru qui a
fait un truc super fort
ok ce que c'est bien joué de la part du
caroux le monstre à il faut aller cacher
ce roi
oh non il s'est fait arnaquer terrible
terrible
alors qu'il était à deux doigts
et il se faire mais aussi la problèmes
de connexion ah mais c'est terrible
l'aco qui l'a lâché
c'est pour ça qu'il a la gale un moment
donné
et oui ça fait mal
sur le dernier fuite
et oui avec une mauvaise qu'au comme ça
c'est vrai que c'est intenable ses
positions dans tous les cas
non mais c'est sûr que la connexion
quand j'ai vu en début de match
connexion à deux barres c'était sûr que
ça
non seulement c'est dur contre hikaru
mais si en plus tu as pas là qu à
ces problématiques quoi pour la 4 points
d'écart problèmes de connexion avec les
bulles est à venir le match est déjà
quasiment plié 1
sur la côte mais bon enfin j'ai envie de
dire où elle se l'est vu la cognition
laquelle il joue il sans ballack aussi
complètement donc pas non plus
mort d'homme
c'est pas non plus un vrai problème quoi
quoi quasiment parce qu'il est moins
fort en bullet sicav ou meilleur
quatre points c'est énorme comme
différence et en plus il a un problème
de connexion donc on les additionne tout
il n'est pas bien oui cela
je pense que dans sa maison de vacances
ou chez paou parce qu'il n'est pas sur
107 ap normal wesley
combat mais c'est sur vitrail de truc
c'est que les joueurs s'en fiche un peu
des compètes sur internet aussi les
joueurs pros
donc en fait s'ils gagnent pas assez
ça lui chante ça change absolument rien
à sa vie quoi ya pas deux
enfin y'a pas assez cool de gagner mais
c'est cool de perdre aussi quoi
enfin si c'était prévu des vacances ou
que je sais pas et dans sa maison de
vacances pendant un moment donné ou quoi
il va pas s'embêter
pour un speech est quoi
on ce qui fait en ce moment wesley
le sait que le town en ligne mois après
il en a gagné quelques-uns mais il était
sur un meilleur c'est ta plage c'est pas
évident ça tape très bizarre
n
pose quand même mais bon
f3
voir ce que ça donne
ce que tu penses pas que la voir
d'évalution permettre aux débutants de
mieux comprendre l'état de la position
assise ainsi si si mais bon après il ya
un autre truc qui est cool c'est de
regarder l'échiquier de regarder la
partie il ya des rebondissements
c'est plus marrant que de regarder une
barre d'évaluation
pour les blancs mais bon
cavalier a du mal à protéger à 6 en fait
mais bon il n'y a pas de bekkaria
carrier qui revient
tutorat un tour des cinq dames c'est de
encore
mc2 direct tour c1 dames prend b3 tout
repenser 5 dame prend à 3 hockey
et des quatre cavaliers à 4
blanc doivent quand même être bien
et tour des cinq ans
adam prend b3 pour penser ça me prend à
ce froid en france évidemment prend un
math
à la haye tellement pris le dessus c'est
terrible il est très difficile à jouer
quand il a quand il commence à
[Musique]
1 dominée dans la tactique
sur sa chaîne youtube du nom sur sa
chaîne prend 1 3% à 3 qui a validé 4
way sur fois à 6,6 à tour à sept et il
va gagner là il va regagner la pièce par
le clouage
ce qu'il a raté un truc
tour à un tour à
8,1 il va faire tourner un
il va contre pouvoir décaler le fou mais
qui va les provinces de tourcoing f2
tour prend assise ça va être égal
et la sueur qui avait laissé cinq c'est
pas une pièce
il a pas ricard ou
hikaru qui n'ont ils commencé à être
insupportable avec ses grimaces à ces
terribles et caro qui commence à être
insupportable assez terrible ça
recommence ça recommence
il n'avait pas l'arrêt fille car où
il fait une tête il écoeuré du tour à 8
à ces terribles
assez terrible
c'est volontaire légaux as bien sûr
c'est magnifique c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
d'or
c'est magnifique
ces manies sic les la file forceurs
ouais c'est pas en forêt il a il a lâché
là c'est sûr qu'il a lâché
qui va gagner
extraordinaire
mais là le match est déjà plié à dos 1
ça fait plaisir
grâce comme ça tu prends une tarderait
je crois qu'il ya un gars qui voulait
aller le
c'était quoi déjà cette histoire je me
rappelle plus c'est un bail que je
connaissais mais un gaillard elle qui a
vraiment voulu défoncer écart ou
physiquement je veux dire
c'était quoi déjà cette histoire
c'est elle et chasse
il ya même un autre bail aussi
un truc avec eric en scène et je vois
qu'il y avait un autre truc aussi
c'était magnifique
jeu plus
bon la position et packer problème c'est
quoi ce les gaffes igaf dur en plus
c'était elle était facile lagaf là
c'était vraiment une grosse grosse
erreur
en reste et il en plein titre la g5 je
pense que c'est un missclick à l'écart
ou qui a fait des grimaces g5 c'était un
mystique
où c'est un tilt au talent fou prend et
wayne il fait n'importe quoi
ok veut faire tour g8 et attaquer mais
quoi que c'était pas si mal mais c'est
plus du tout dans son sillage
trop ouais il essaye de se faire plaisir
clic un peu quoi
c'est peut-être bien là ce qu'il fait en
vrai wesley
c'est juste tellement pas dans son style
allez
avec fou prend des six dames hk 3g un g3
je pense
j'imagine c'est un truc comme ça
on m'en donnait à la fin quand il fait
qu'il est proche d'être avec talent adam
décalé your adam prend 1,5 sur échec
c'est peut-être ça qui l'a raté
meybon fo
b57 salaire de faire mal
l'écart ou qui veulent à défendre
donc après cette partie aura une petite
pause 1-2 nouveau pour être bien sûr
truc marrant avec damache 4g six tours à
6 pour d'art machin maths mais c'est
très dur à trouver c'est pas sûr qu'ils
la gagnent bon si personal match est
vraiment terminée plus un qui revient à
+4 c'est dur mais ça peut encore
s'y lie à
+6 à +6 assez merci au revoir 1
c'est déjà
en dix ans le chat presque
walaja d'en prendre cinq échecs il a
juste raté
et tout reprend f7
il se trouve que l'âge et le petit ordi
qui y aide je regarde plus le redis
quand les matches sont gagnés à food et
4 aussi qu'il ya eu en fait il ya tout
qui gagne
il arrive à une mentalement wesley
belle finale
belle finale il fout des cuatro et se
termine à dos
ils exagèrent ses grimaces comme ça je
suis pas à ça le fait marrer
il n'y a pas de raison
ouais + 4 c'est terminé les gars +6
s'est terminée par dont jusqu'à tu avais
encore un un espoir
donc là il ya la petite pause pour être
bien sûr vous restez qui est dégoûté
et c'est vrai que là les matchs sont
loin barrett façon c'est pour ça que le
format va pas du tout
tu as une finale est à la dernière heure
et quart de spectacle qui à zéro intérêt
mais bon
c'est pas grave on s'emballe est qu un
peu aussi il faut le dire
c'est nouveau c'est pause ouais c'est
pour mettre plus de pub en bray
a perdu 1 + 4 ouais mais joue à la rage
dans un hôtel à dubaï
il aurait jamais dû perdre mais juste
il jouait pas très sérieux hein
il jouait pas très sérieux non plus
évidemment il aurait bien aimé gagner
mais bon c'était pas ils jouaient pas sa
vie là dessus un
comparons ce qui est comparable 1
comparons ce qui est comparable
bassékou l'a1 c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est
cool
c'est pareil autre
oui mais ses fins et ça c'est
complètement différent quand caruana
aussi un ces îles sont ils s'en fichent
et un peu en vrai
mais c'est ça quand les deux joueurs
s'en fiche un peu il peut pas tout peut
arriver en fait
quand les deux s'en fiche un peu tout
peut arriver
carrousel à tout le monde sait qu'il ya
oui car où c'est qu'il a gagné sauce et
qu'il a perdu tous les spectateurs
savent que le match est déjà à moins
d'un truc incroyable déco coire en plus
la hesse ouest il a les problèmes de
court donc
les déconnexions peuvent même pas être
comme entrecôtes et côtes et hikaru quoi
donc c'est vraiment difficile
la coc peut même pas être en faveur
enfin
et donc c
c'est très complexe
panne 2
deux courants
le pneumothorax
toujours
a perdu 2 à cause de la côte
est après il a juste il a juste qu'il va
pas pris car haut et plus fort c'est
toujours pareil c'est c'est
ces événements contraire quand ils
arrivent au joueur le plus fort ça donne
des matchs plus serré voire même des
surprises quand il arrive du coup quand
ils arrivent au joueur qui est déjà
moins fort je sature les matchs
en moi ça me fait très plaisir que ça se
joue à l'aco en gris tout cas perdu à la
côte du golfe a perdu à l'aco la finale
se joue un peu à la co aussi c'est
extraordinaire ce magnifique
ce magnifique ça fait plaisir
moi je suis très heureux quand ça se
joue là dessus ans et c'est le truc qui
me fait le plus plaisir
c'est quoi le cas je crois que c'est pas
grand-chose france et vingt mille balles
je crois que c'est pas énorme
un an vingt mille bas un an pour pour
les joueurs de haut niveau non c'est
comme si tu dis cinquante mille balles
par mois pour neymar tu te rends bien
compte que c'est rien dire il faut
comparer ce qui est comparable
tu prends tu prends le championnat du
monde c'est un million deux tu prends tu
prends n'importe quelle grande chez
source et 150000 tu prends n'importe
quel championne tour c'est au moins
cinquante ou soixante quinze mille et ça
joue sur sur six jours
c'est pas énorme pour les joueurs qui
sont les meilleurs du monde fin faut
réfléchir en comparaison avec ce qu'ils
gagnent habituellement
je sais pas neymar par contre les
contrats pub qui doit avoir sur twitch
l'esa b to c faisant un jeu confirma
pour les pourceaux non plus c'est pas
grand chose
alors du coup c'est comme il a des
problèmes de connexion ça tout en l'air
à chaque fois
c'est comme ça les joueurs de haut
niveau c'est pas grand chose si on
disait que neymar était payé 50 mille
euros par an tu ne dirais pas que c'est
beaucoup d'argent
comparativement aux autres pas premier
laddh millions mais j'en sais rien je
n'ai pas pu les payer mais marc mais
puissant tir et que c'est pas beaucoup
d'argent
par rapport à ce qu'il a gagné par là
c'est pareil
façon ça se voit enfin si c'était si
important ouest et j'aurai dans des
conditions optimales
j'aime gagner rien mais ils ont déjà
gagné des trucs mais si gagnera quelque
chose aussi c'est peut-être quinze mille
de différences ou 10000 j'en sais rien
moi mais c'est pas une somme
pour ces gens là c'est pas une somme ce
pas une grande somme en fait
la regarde maxime par exemple mvele il
est parti en vacances pour le premier
tour il était en vacances à dubaï quand
tu oublies jouer le premier tour alors
ils auraient quand même pu gagner mais
si c'est des choses importantes et que
c'est des grosses sommes pour toi tu vas
pas aller en vacances quand tu joues le
truc
donc
notable du social est ce que ça
financièrement ah oui bah oui gagnent
tous beaucoup
et tant mieux mais je veux juste dire
que c'est pas
c'est tant mieux pour eux c'est bien
mais
mais c'est pas à les motiver à bien
jouer en fait
c'est pas un 1
alors là ça va être une partie troll
10 à
ses finances et là je pense ça doit être
financé à bata des sponsors et puis au
delà de ça
tu as tous les gens qui sont abonnés sur
chasse comme donc ça peut être financée
comme ça c'est sûrement là j'imagine
et les autres tournois où il ya beaucoup
plus de prix du coup c'est beaucoup du
mécénat
très complexe
après peut-être le plus marrant
maintenant s'il n'ya pas qu'ils
étrangers trois
enfants j'ai trois fous pranger 3 puis
on prend g3 il doit y avoir dame prend
h1 il va y avoir ton prendre trois tons
proches des trois âges de plus marrant
c'est d'être pourri car vous espérez le
score le plus gros possible
même ali reza qui arrivait dans le top10
récemment péan lui fassions à mai mais
en fait c'est enfin vous n'imaginez pas
en fait il ya une vraiment très bien
leur vie et fille c'est tant mieux
mais oui très très facilement
passe même pas ils vivent très très bien
tout de suite en fait
les joueurs doivent payer pour partir en
tournée au niveau maintenant ils sont
payés seulement ils ont même un starting
fille ils sont même payés pour
participer au tournoi généralement
au-delà du prix qu'ils obtiennent ils
ont tous les frais payés les voyages les
machins
via les sponsors un an généralement ils
n'ont pas de sens mais si vous allez
tournoi
il faut g4
c'est ça joue plus les coûts la
saya plus attention il ya plus les coûts
là
là ça clique au hasard sa clique au
hasard
annoncé ces terribles à part la partie n
ya pas trop de lyon en fait c'est dur a
commenté parce qu'il ya pas trop de lyon
maxime ce n'est pas faux regardez ses
gains en tournoi mais je crois que juste
à l'asim que phil cup au grand-duché
saut il a déjà pris 150 milles maximum
quelque chose comme ça
juste sur sur le grande chaise tours
sur le circuit du grand duché ce tour au
dernier truc donc il gagne bien aussi
mais face c'est tant mieux
[Musique]
ben ouais ça va échanger
c'est pas un match serré c'est là les
parties
n'est pas allé par ye li hai a plus les
coûts en fait ça ça clique fait quoi
sakic puis appuyez coup ça sent que
plus sokhna cave juste finir le match et
ça sent qu'il a qui veulent en fait
ils cliquent pas ce qui doit cliquer
il clique parce qu'il doit cliquer il
reste encore une heure ouais
mais ça se sent dans les coûts
de la passe qu'il doit rester là après
peut aussi avoir un truc qui se passent
des fois quand tu joues un peu comme ça
en dilettante
tu peux amener l'adversaire dans un faux
rythme en gagne une deux tu reviens dans
le match c'est ce qu'il faut espérer
pour lui
et
ça va qui est en âge cette
chaussure qu'il a rien calculer quoi
c'est extraordinaire
je pense qu' à partir pour x 7 3 7 kg 5
d'un match 5 je sais pas si ça gagne pas
je pensais qu'ils allaient partir pour
ça
qui
ouais après c'est tellement dur comme
jeu mentalement les échecs quand ça
devient dur dans les matches où tu es
obligé de continuer c'est un peu pareil
le match championnat du monde mais ça
lâche un peu bon là c'est plus facile
l'achat ouais c'est vrai parce que je
pense qu'il y avait du fou prend h7 qui
donnait envie
mais ça n'a pas été joué
l'aica où il a entraîné dans le faux
rythme aussi
ça peut servir wesley cette histoire de
faux rythme il faut qu'il a un peu de
beau lui qu'il en gagne une deux
même temps
c'est dur d'y croire parce que
bahia le scénario du match
il ya les cookies sont jouées qui sont
plus les coups qu'on a l'habitude de
voir quoi
qui gagne celle là
du monde c'était vraiment pas terrible à
suivre
on n'est pas tu es en termes de
compétition malheureusement j'espère que
le championnat du monde de billes c'est
rapide sera cool je pense que ce sera
bien
là le pion en train de filer
il va peut-être faire même retourner
encore wesley
annonce havas tour à 5,5 ou bien
jouer il va bloquer l'avancée du pion
s'est tarie ok c'est bien jouer où il
veut tomber 800 points f7
avec un peu de bol elle peut bien tourné
le bo lui qui peut se présenter
car ou qui défend pas mal encore et non
ça va pas suffire
oui car ou là est ce qu'il veut c'est
juste tourner le début des bulles est à
+ 6 +71
tranquillement
à tour prend g7
en voyant h quattro ici
bref
3.445 tout reprend h quatre tours échec
à et l'envoie dans ce sens là
la cam ils ont encore un problème de
calmes
il faut réussir à faire quelque chose au
réussir à la gagner
pour mettre un peu de piment
dans ce match qui en manque cruellement
s'arrêter la première heure de jeu au
final
terrible bassin
mais qu'est ce que c'est le format qui
veut ça là les joueurs ils sont vraiment
pour rien
parce que je suis cinq rapports et
caruana non non mais morale gasimov je
suis pas
m'intéresse pas trop ce tournoi
peut-être fait retour des sacs à main ce
tour des 5 c'était fort sur eux deux ils
avaient tous reçu 5 il a raté un truc
assez facile à wesley
il est plus dedans
allez peut-être il va quand même la
gagner dans la qualité de jeu a quand
même bien baissé 1
l'aca a bien baissé bref trois points je
prends la sicav ou qui a pas très bien
défendu mika ou qui a fait n'importe
quoi ça le fait rigoler
il sait que il doit jamais perdre ce
genre de partie
il va la jouer jusqu'au bout pour faire
tourner la pendule c'est bien joué 1 à
pardies car ou
alors il sait pas faire du sénat c'est
terrible
va y arriver
vas y arriver
bon là il a la tête dans le seau mai à
lille en a gagné une qui sait ça peut
peut-être
peut-être reprendre un peu de poil de la
bête
il s'en sort bien sur la dernière wesley
et c'est vrai qu'ils jouent un peu en
tilt et il a un peu amener hikaru dans
un faux rythme
et ça peut parfois être une chance
par ce match qui semblait complètement
gagnée pour ricard ou hyper cela il a
perdu la précédente ils repèrent cela il
se retrouve à plus 4
il suffit qu'il ya encore une ou deux
qui tourne en faveur de wesley derrière
parce qu'il était quand même dominateurs
dans le jeu
avant avant les crew lada
et tout d'un coup il peut se retrouver à
- 3 - 2 - 3 et alors là après tout est
possible
alors on en est loin de ce scénario
encore
il peut y avoir un tout petit rennes jld
il peut y lire un tout petit rennes jld
il faut faire ces trois un petit peu
bloqué limiter le fou et envoyer la dame
verbe et trois tours d un tour e1
et un b3 d un tourin et
jouets ça on va voir si cars ou se remet
complètement
normalement là il doit fermer la porte
tout de suite hikaru
et sortir une grosse game je pense qu'il
va y arriver un
trop long
sans doute histoire chez soi je donnerai
de outre 2 pour 1 ou 2%
il ya aussi la connexion à prendre en
compte est le fait qu'ils jouent sur un
ordi un peu un peu un peu pour av
mais bon
s'ils tournent à - 3 - 2 ovules est ça
peut le faire
j'ai trois caches 3g 2
il fait autour des deux projets d'en
prendre et devait remettre la tour en d1
on sa clique pas mal
il faut peut-être joué avec d'amd de fou
g3 essayer de chasser
normalement dames et cavaliers c'est
plus fort que dame est fou mais la
structure est un peu meilleures pour les
blancs beau ça doit être plus ou moins
égales prendrait plutôt les noirs quand
même mais
là hikaru qui a clairement céréens il a
serré la vis ici
à foot et 4 il n'a pas d'âme des six 6 e
5 grammes cette foule 3 qui avait allégé
6e des il a laissé un pion hikaru je
crois à il a encore ils attaquent encore
achevé sur agen qui là encore cavaliers
au 7 mai ouais il n'était pas loin de
[Musique]
de perdre un pion là le niveau de jeu a
clairement fléchi 1
le niveau 2 ont fléchi
d'un f2 j'imagine ici
23 arrêts pour que la finale doit être
un peu avantageuse des pions sont fixés
sur noir il ya un pion isolé il ya
peut-être des mondes où ils bloquent les
pions avec un 4 à 5 i à iv des cats à
saint-cloud quelque chose comme ça
bref de ici peut être un coup d'ailleurs
pour g4 est sûrement la finale est
avantageuse pour les blancs
un
g4 ça et maintenant il va faire quoi 4
des quatre
intéressant quand ils essayent de
presser cette finale parce que les pions
sont quand même bien fixer un
dea fou prend 1,7
et qui à roue du but hâtif
voir s'il ya une seule est revient à
quatre points
et tout d'un coup le match qui se
relance un peu
ko qui s'est un peu endormi avec ses
grimaces
ça peut être vain manche sur un jour
noir
faut faire gaffe même un plomb comme fou
c'est un fois à trois fois fuite qui
peut arriver un jour
c'est réellement difficile à jouer
mais bon ça doit se tenir encore
c17 et sûr
faut se poser la question si fou des six
gagnants
roy prend pions prend il doit penser
qu'en fait ils bloquent les cases
d'entrée ça doit être nul
f4 ça donne la case de 4 mai doit avoir
foulé fuite
f5 roi 17
décanat le truc c'est que là ils fixent
un
roi des rois des cas 3c 6
3 des 4 il veut quoi roi des kataëb et 5
maintenant
vous prend roi prend cedro
un tarif pas à percer
3,17 n'arrive pas à percer
et du coup ils attendent comme ça
il veut roi ici roi des 4 et maintenant
cavalier e 5 pour cavaliers pranger
4è fit d'abord et pranger quatre fous
pranger cette attention le fou peut se
faire enfermer henri vii 3g 8 c'est
terrible or voulons la force et il va la
perdre
c'est pas possible oh c'est terrible
et ce à sa clôture clôturait de wesley
et oui il a voulu la forcer il se fait
clôture des
cavs a lieu un il va essayer d'aller
choper lyon tu
as
si ski épreuve 6 3 prend v6 qui est
proche 5 ces cinq cavaliers f 4 3 6 6 3
des arts ou à ses six cavaliers detroit
et à et sur ses six avec cavaliers
chèque est il bloqué la case
est terrible il se fait clôturer
clôture et là ça fait plus si c'est
terrible en petits carreaux a très bien
défendu et c'est là qu'il est fort c'est
là qu'il est très fort le joueur
américain
et oui la survenue à +4 y avait encore
une petite chance mais six points
d'écart
on va pas se mentir
on ne va pas se mentir
clôture aide s'était déjà cuits mais ça
l'est encore plus
ne mentons pas
c'est ça c'est complètement ça le match
et clôtures aide
à
terrible 1 et 6 points d'écart qui font
qu'ils font clairement très mal
voilà mes et soit maintenant tu vas plus
rien rater un
est ce que tu viens d'ailleurs au stage
au portugal ou pas monsieur p soir est
ce qu'on sait si on va te revoir ou pas
le sait-on
on cherche un petit tour le hb fait
encore du salat du trait salins
du très très sale
il a vraiment bien je la d1 partie oui
voici qui a essayé de la forcer au final
s'est retourné contre lui
vicat autriche non
pas du tout juste il est plus fort
c'est simplement un meilleur joueur
c'est tout un
ni plus ni moins
ni plus ni moins élaborés cela
maintenant il a vraiment la tête sous
l'eau 1
l'eau
c'est comme ça
juste là ça
je peux
points d'écart et hikaru vais encore de
l'arnaqué c'est vraiment vraiment
difficile
il mérite un émérite il mérite sicav ou
ya rien a dire
il ya absolument
à 10 ans
il a fait son match
il a été solide dans les positions
complexes
et comment sa rage et ben
c'est désagréable parce que tu sais que
ta match perdu tu sais que l'autre veut
troubler dessus et puis ça a plus à rien
de jouer tu comprends même plus pourquoi
tu joues en fait
à vrai dire la place des os les sas fin
ça saoule en fait je sais même pas
pourquoi tu joue réellement
la côte est tu as qu'une envie c'est de
rage quit le truc en fait
si tu pouvais en fait tu rage quit
si tu pouvais tu kit
tu peux pas mais
ça c'est un autre problème
y a pas d'abandon possible dans toutes
les pièces qui arrivent sur le roi 1 qui
a valu à 25
bhl
chèques non cavaliers prend et dans la
tour prends des huit
voies cki gaffe on a sept points d'écart
l atom j'ai joué jusqu'au bout
ouais c'est
c'est aussi désagréable à jouer pour
hikaru que pour wesley en réalité que
pour nous de regarder est obligé de voir
l'humiliation d'un homme ce n'est pas
forcément très agréable en vrai c'est un
peu du sadisme
est obligé de jouer en c1 7 a déjà perdu
trois
ans les beats sont bizarres ou non elles
sont pas bizarre
se retrouve contre flash ça dépend en
partie réelle c'est pas la même mais là
ouais sur ces formats sur internet c'est
dur
mais là c'est terrible
comme jiwa s'il n'a pas très bien joué
tout au long de la compétition je suis
pas étonné de ne pas le voir à 100% ici
après l'avait réalisé un beau début de
match
on va avoir une demi-heure de bullet
c'est peut-être moins pénible juste
cliquer
juste combien le pauvre tu as encore une
demi heure à jouer derrière
terrible
bon allez faut qu'ils faut qu'il s'en
gagne il faut qu'ils essaient d'en
gagner quelques-unes os les là il a une
belle position
quatre jours quelque temps avec le plus
le à chambly de carl scène clairement
car la scène c'est un peu l'anti d'auto
h en fait
qu'est ce qu'il fait différence de
niveau et cargo sur les carences rapide
après là c'est vraiment sur les cadences
rapides sur internet 1 parce qu'il ya le
bullet aussi qui le favorise donc là
aussi aujourd'hui joue pas très bien il
n'a pas très bien joué les autres jours
mais contre dingoo quoi c'est loin
d'être sûr qu'ils
auraient gagnés fin en fait il aurait
sûrement pas gagné en vrai
c'est vraiment le format qui lui
convient le mieux au niveau des cadences
au niveau du fait qu'il a plus
l'habitude de jouer sur internet
le fait que les matches soient très long
avec beaucoup de partis qui s'enchaînent
aussi
donc ouais
il est plus fort ça c'est sûr
et on verra championnat du monde 1 de
façon c'est danser dans une semaine
maintenant
on verra dans une semaine s'ils gagnent
ou parent il y aura alors à champagne
monte de rapides et de blitz
et on verra là à ce moment là on pourra
juger de
mieux juger de sa
ce qui arrive ouais il jouera là il faut
prendre les trois noms mais la wes les
hits roll juste
ou sci troll la game fort
bon il tente il tente un truc ça peut
marcher
il tente un truc
dix ans on peut un peu
comme si au tennis il y avait un joueur
qui était vraiment plus fort que les
autres sur parquet
je le rappelais plus qu'à l'équipe de
coupe davis avait fait jouer l'espagne
sur sur park et d'ailleurs et nadal
avait perdu les deux matchs de mémoire
alors qu'à l'époque il était numéro 1 au
numéro deux mondial mais ce serait la
bonne analogie quoi
mais
mais faut être un bon joueur de tennis
pour être bon sur parquet aussi mais
c'est un truc un peu un peu spécial quoi
la can gagnée saint louis sans perdre un
seul match car oui c'était pas en ligne
ouais mais avait pas magnus avait pas
mvl
il n'y avait pas les meilleurs
mais vous me faites disent que j'ai pas
dis c'est un excellent joueur hikaru
mais il n'est pas top 1 mondial dans
aucune cadence
mais le truc c'est que vous
vous êtes à l'envers de la réalité
est là encore des problèmes de coûts en
plus c'est terrible
alors mon jeu
même chose mille fois ci voulait pas
comprendre vous comprenez pas moi la
rigueur je m'en fous complètement aussi
donc tu vas faire le père pète si l'aco
de wes les tiens
et ça fait drôle il reste encore 30
minutes de souffrance pour wesley une
petite pub
et on revient
dans trois minutes
petit demi heures de souffrance
le jeu gagne à ses adversaires elle n'a
pas résolu juin mais c'est clairement le
joueur actuellement
le plus fort du monde
mais il n'a pas à proprement dire résolu
jeu quoi
il joue mieux que les autres
ware qui arrivera un jour peut-être
alireza peut-être un autre mais qui sera
plus fort que magnus et et l'histoire du
sport suivra son cours habituel tout
simplement
c'est comme ça le sport le sport suit
son cours
et les générations de joueurs se
suivaient il faudra un énorme joueur
pour détrôner
magnus comme il avait fallu un énorme
joueur pour détrôner karpov comme il
avait fallu un énorme joueur pour
détrôner caspar a fait
et l'histoire des échecs
suit son cours est tout simplement
demi heure dans ce match
[Musique]
on va attendre le début de la dernière
portion
et chaque oeil a pas de recherche
vraiment pour dopage
j'en arrive en désaccord et pas man
comes back non là sept points c'est ses
rideaux
salut qu'à une merci pour tes sprinter
intéressante bien que je débarque un peu
tard mais est ce que tu penses que
déclare magnus un portier rouge de ce
championnat du monde était une façon
discrète dire que tu veux devrait
prendre la tête de la chine en mer je
pense que magnus y en a peut-être marre
des mâles championnat du monde il veut
peut-être aussi push son business et est
essayé de trouver des sponsors pour
organiser ses propres matches un peu à
l'instar de kasparov
et peut-être ils préparent elles
préparent peut-être une scission avec la
figure en sais rien moi
pourquoi car le sait n'a pas participé
puisqu'il avait le match du championnat
du monde
andré avec l'émergence du championnt
tour aussi donc l'autre compétition
salle co organise justement magnus
carlsen et beaucoup de tournois sur
internet et ça a vraiment
créé un genre de ras-le-bol même même
des joueurs de ces tournois sur le net
donc en quelque sorte c'est pas
surprenant qui est que même que même
wesley so ou quoi ils soient moins
impliqué ce qui est beaucoup de ces
tournois
et les joueurs sont quand même content
que les échecs en réel et repris à la à
la suite
par la suite de l'épidémie de kobe de
parce que ça continue et on va dire que
les jouer les tournois pendant quasiment
un an n'ont pas eu lieu et là maintenant
il réorganise quand même les trois
d'échecs avec les normes sanitaires et
caetera et donc c'est vrai que les
joueurs sont peut-être plus attiré par
l'entraînement et par le retour à la
compétition réelle que par ces tournois
sur internet
don
entre guillemets ce qui va ce qui va se
passer là dessus
mais que
magnus a la chance de lui dans le pays
stockfisch s'amusant mais
amusé aide
amusé de les amis
la défense c'est très joli en deuxième
game je crois aux trois mois il ya eu un
joli début de match mais c'est un des
trucs qui est bien avec le format 7
c'est que ça permet aux joueurs même si
t'as perdu un set ou deux de
d'essayer de te re motiver pour le cet
avenir là le truc c'est que le match il
est tué tu sais que tu peux pas revenir
ce sera en trois sets gagnants y aurait
peut-être de 7,02 partout dans le
troisième et tu sais que si tu gagnes tu
peux clutch et tu reviens
mais amel a le format laisse pas de
come-back et du coup c'est très
difficile pour wesley de
d'avoir envie de jouer tout simplement
ouais les mains bonne lecture
ça va repartir
voilà j'espère vraiment juste pour
wesley qui va pas prendre trop cher que
le match va vite terminée pour lui
parce que c'est vraiment
très franchement c'est juste un mauvais
moment à passer
tu as joué controversé jouer une partie
m'a battue
et ça repart 1
que les joueurs en fait
ouais c'est issue avec sa connexion
c'est terrible
ouais c'est issue avec sa connexion à il
a pas de connexion c'est terrible
est non seulement il est moins fort mais
en plus il a pas de co
et le classent les résultats en tout ces
derniers résultats des cadences
mis fin à parts et déjà sari
une demi heure une demi heure de bullet
par beaucoup avec sa connexion il a
perdu pas mal de temps alors
c'est pas ça qu'il aura forcément fait
perdre mais on va dire que c'est ça
qu'il aura fait
complètement basculé dans la défaite
entre conte roanne avait été sympa
d'ailleurs il avait il avait laissé là
le match nul après un problème de
connexion de fabiano il n'était pas
obligé la ja personnes qui rien fait
pour sa connexion s'est pour sa part
fois qu'on vous dit ouais c'est pas fair
play tout problème de connexion tu peux
tu peux laisser un demi point tu peux
laisser quelque chose en vrai le truc
c'est quand ça t'arrive ya jamais
personne qui vient td donc
je trouve ça assez normal tant que c'est
dans les règles de
banon j'ai gagné à la cause j'ai gagné
là qu en fait tant pis un
c'est pas de bol c'est dégueu de gagner
à la cause c'est tout ce que tu veux
mais il se trouve que c'est les règles
et le jour où sa taille voire la la il
est déconnecté d'internet arriver là
vraiment eu beaucoup de problèmes de
connexion pendant le match wesley est en
fait c'est pas un problème interne est
sympa le serveur chess comme
c'est pas sa connexion qui est
problématique c'est le serveur ouais
c'est pas la première fois que ça arrive
dans ce match ça lui aura coûté au moins
deux points
donc je veux pas du tout dire que hikaru
a gagné là dessus mais c'est ça qui aura
fait tourner définitivement le match en
sa faveur
après ses belles compétitions en moi
j'aime bien compétitions qui jouent la
finale se joue à la cause ça fait
plaisir
mais là on a bien vu avec la caméra qui
bouge et que c'est pas du tout un
problème de connexion c'est juste un
problème de connexion serveurs donc il
n'est pas du tout responsable de south
là il se fait rennes je t'en fait
ouest c'est sympa même de connexion aux
serveurs
mais c'est vrai qu'au moment un peu
serré du match là quand il y avait deux
points d'écart deux parties qu'il aurait
pu peut-être gagner ou faire nul il a il
est un peu été trahi par sa autant et ça
ça ben salah fait complètement
dégoupillé sortir du match
et là ça coûte cher aussi parce que les
bayahi père salah sur la côte aussi sans
les problèmes de qu il appert pas et ça
dégoûte sicard est aussi un peu dégoûté
après le match vous quand même beaucoup
là dessus on va on va être complètement
francs
le score est si élevé à cause de ça et
caro qui se bat on sait pas pourquoi
c'est comme si quelqu'un avait parlé
aussi lisez quelque chose en même temps
c'est bizarre de rigoler comme ça de
manière absolument
aller à tous ac le banc claude je
regardais sa caméra
désolé je regardais la caméra 10 kg
pourquoi il se marre je n'avais pas
réalisé
très clairement ce haut salat fait
dégoupiller une bonne fois pour toutes
ouais c'est pas qu'il ya plus de respect
c'est que
honnêtement quand tu joues s'accusant
encore se taper une demi heure de match
que tu as été déconnecté sur trois
parties a minima qui t'ont coûté 3 game
que le score ça va pas qui a rien qui va
t'on n'a plus rien à faire un
temps n'a en affaires mais là hikaru va
lui faire le banc claude aussi ça va
être n'importe quoi pendant une demi
heure
magnifique ah bah voilà les compètes
qu'on aime pas ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas commenter un match de
speechless et je dois dire que j'ai
choisi mon match
c'est des matches magnifiques un
sas a fait ça fait plaisir
extraordinaire
ah bah oui
le boycott c'est quand tu bouges ton
rang aux deux ans aux usa absolument à
rien c'est juste quand on a absolument
plus rien à [ __ ]
ah bah oui magnifique une finale comme
ça
on se demande pourquoi les joueurs ne
prennent pas la compétition au sérieux
oui c'est magnifique
ça fait plaisir on voit le chilien ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu le
chilien
c'est terrible ça
c'est de mises sont joués à un point
d'écart
oh ben non moi je suis très content
je suis très content robin side
au contraire un
à toi tu toi tu penses
je suis très heureux
pour moi c'est extraordinaire un match
comme ça
des petits rois 17 les machins c'est
magnifique
ah ben oui c'est magnifique
ils vont être réprimandés par 14 non je
te rassure ça fait c'est la cinquième
saison la sixième saison que ça arrive
c'est toujours pareil ça change pas donc
non pour tout le monde s'en fout en fait
c'est extraordinaire
c'est mon petit plaisir avant avant les
vacances de noël un petit match comme ça
je suis heureux 1
je suis très heureux
c'est les échecs qu'on aime voir ah bah
oui
c'est du très haut niveau là on est en
train de voir ensemble
seba la taille du tournoi c'est
magnifique
le titre vient apporter ici que sur le
banc claude
là c'est con tu chies sur ta raquette
avant de servir ya plus de il n'y a plus
rien à dire
un mot sur du full troll
on est sur du full troll hikaru qui
encore la connexion qui tombe mais je
crois qu'en fait il a vraiment eu
beaucoup de problèmes de connexion dans
le match on est on sait pas forcément
rendu compte mais je pense c'est ça qui
l'a fait totalement tilt à un moment
donné
à l'écart et dipra f3 ici et il a pas il
peut pas reprendre du cavalier et adam
prend hélas du coup il perd des 2 et
services à écuires c'est pas avant que
le nom
service à la cuillère c'est mieux
annoncé à
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on force
les joueurs à jouer jusqu'au bout pour
voir ça en fait enfin je pense que rien
est plus intéressant mais
je ne peux pas comprendre en fait il ya
des choses qui me dépassent
c'est juste moche de voir ça en fait
c'est juste moche on sent qu'il ya un
joueur qui veut vraiment plus jouer qui
a vraiment pas d'internet je me répète
mais
injuste il est même pas dans des
conditions normales pour jouer en plus
ça vient pas de lui un ça vient pas de
wesley c'est pas de son fait c'est une
simple problèmes de connexions serveurs
en finale de la compet et touche
qu'enfin je comprends qu'il soit il tint
bon genre bout d'un moment c'est pas ton
crête jeune tchèque en fait tout à
l'heure et on voyait que
son set up fonctionner
vers le set up de hikaru n'est plus
n'est plus là puisqu'il a plus qu'une
caméra est la plus la caméra derrière
donc voir énoncés
c'est quand même sean en fait tu perds
ton truc sur copains tu perds ton truc
son serveur tu as des problèmes tu peux
pas défendre tes chances de manière
équitable et en plus on t'oblige à jouer
pendant pendant quatre heures cessession
séssion ses charmes pour s les
choix qui fait ap
n'importe quoi ils filent des pièces en
maille à d'improbables 6 en fait
il veut qu'ils avaient projet 4 mai à
tours pranger catane 36 software étant
pranger ktk et prend des 8 enfin h cissé
à mais bon il a juste une pièce de -
enfin
c'est complètement foutue iclic vraiment
au hasard là
il quitte vraiment au hasard il est il
est full tilt le pauvre
ne peut plus jouer
là il veut plus jouer
et quand ça arrive c'est dur
quand ça arrive ce genre de choses c'est
dur moi je turbo jeu turbo à 26 80 quand
ça arrive il ya un moment donné tu as
une réaction je sais pas pourquoi tu
perds en boucle comme ça et à un moment
donné des fois t'es une réaction
d'orgueil tu te remets à jouer normal
parce que tant peu plus et là c'est
moche
non c'est terrible c'est encore
complètement vrai nom c'est ça me
dégoûte de voir ça en fait c'est juste
triste
voici ce fou de foot pro f trop fins
ça dégoûte de voir ça en fait
enfin il joue plus en fait
je vais
non explosées quoi
et qui a généré ben parce qu'il sait ce
qui se passe et il comprend le truc de
co et tous faim n'est pas stupide hikaru
là il comprend que
c'est tout match
ça va pas du tout on va voir si réussi
un peu à se remettre
allez ça va et cargo a l'air d'avoir
laissé à passer un truc
jeu hans fehr les éditions change alors
à foug détrompe toi
j'espère que les règles ne changeront
pas c'est quand même dommage ce serait
dommage ça fait quand même six ans que
c'est comme ça ou sept ce serait dommage
que les règles changent
lourd sympa de voir ça
oh ça gagne pour wesley
joli tour est fait un tour d un
allaient s'arracher un outil un petit
sourire à wesley
ça fait plaisir quidam eux deux
et caro qui laisse sa tournée la peau
nue quand même pour être bien sûr
à
à jouer jusqu'au bout pour bien bien
faire tourner la pendule
on sait jamais que les 13 points ne
suffisent pas
ah bah oui il n'y a que 13 points
d'écart
ce serait dommage
ça c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
alley damage 5 peut-être nom d'anne des
deux
allemagnes quittera l'on ne jouant pas
au c'est magnifique il fait pas d'âme
bessette tempo assez extraordinaire ah
non il avait un problème de connexion au
la connexion qui lui fuit encore c'est
magnifique il a plus de co non mais
c'est là qu'on voit qu'il a d'énormes
problèmes de co2 puis tout le match en
fait ils n'arrivent pas à jouer tempo
ah oui non mais en fait c'est en fait
ils avaient vraiment aucune chance dans
ce match
il fait exprès de pas maté vite en fait
ouais c'est pour avoir moins deux
parties à jouer
assez extraordinaire hikaru qui attend
j'adore assez magnifique quel spectacle
les amis
je pense qu'on restait va troller va
aussi attendre magnifique s'il fait ça
un écart ou qu'ils abandonnent avec 0 0
un magnifique
assez extraordinaire quel spectacle
à ceux qui encore déconnecté oh c'est
terrible non en fait ça c'est n'importe
quoi ce match fait ya jamais eu match en
vrai comment comment il a pu jouer en
fait tout le long
et là encore je voyais son écran c'est à
un bug serveurs chess comme il s'est
fait bug chaise comme serveur pendant
tout le truc quoi ah ça dégoûte pour lui
non mais c'est pas lui qui a une
mauvaise connexion alliance ova c'est le
serveur
c est fou de [ __ ] la faute sur wesley
tu vois bien à la came to kill et il n'a
pas de problème
c'était
en fait dans les règles si un problème
serveur comme cdu entre guillemets
hasard ou quoi et tu peux pas vraiment
savoir d'où ça vient ça joue en fait
c'est un peu comme s'il pleut dans un
stade où quoi s'arrêter hikaru qui
auraient eu les problèmes soir était la
même
ça aurait rien changé en fait cessé dans
la règle en fait c'est un problème de
connexion avec le serveur comme c'est
difficile de déterminer d'où ça vient
en fait ça peut être avec ton
ton opérateur internet peut avoir plein
de raisons pour lesquelles tu as un
problème serveurs qui peut même être
extérieur au serveur lui même et donc
dans tous les cas en fait le match
aurait été rejouée
ne revenez pas été rejouée pardon
mais
dans le match en fait on s'en était
moins rendu compte hors du bullet parce
que je regardais - mais j'imagine qu'il
a eu ce problème à beaucoup de reprises
durant le match est clairement sur les
parties clutch qui ont fait tourner plus
ou moins
le truc ça a changé pas mal de choses
l'écart aurait quand même gagné je pense
mais ça aurait pu être un match vraiment
serré
il reste encore douze minutes à subir
pour rester
perdre ça la
voix du coup c'est quand même s'il avait
entrepris entre 15 et 30 secondes de
moins chaque partie ait commencé on a vu
qu'il ya beaucoup de partis qui sont
joués à rien ça ça fait la différence
le fou du roi fahd jouer maintenant son
petit écran
j'ai tellement ri pour tu seras sur les
scop ou non sur les sur ma chaîne
j'aurais pas les calmes du coup mais je
reste sur ma chaîne pour le rapide pour
le blitz je sais pas encore
ça va il a dit tiens cela wesley
maxime a participé au tournoi
ouais il se fait éliminer au premier
tour
ça se doit être nul
ouais
tu crois maximo candidats ouais bien sûr
j'espère que maxime sera au candidat
ok
qu'est ce qu'il faut
j'ai basque car ou en fait
ça a joué qu'en pro maxime les candidats
cas il faut candidats ça va jouer à
en février mars avril ou
non la f1 j'essaye de jouer le maximum
de coups pour hikaru qui fait perdre du
temps pour avoir le minimum deux parties
comme ils mènent au score
restait qui va carrément sur ses mails
de ses magnifiques voix sur son écran
c'est boris barque arrive en chef comme
quoi
c'est beau ça le soul tellement
c'est magnifique un
ballet encore huit minutes
ces mini toi
le centre est longue
on verra on verrait vers verte chaise
comme pour voir la fin
ça aura été magnifique
ça aurait été un magnifique match comme
on les aime
je resterai peut-être deux trois parties
encore
voilà qui perd le plus un peu bêtement
le match est très serré
terrible
jeu ce que les deux ils ont envie de
jouer au minimum deux parties ça qui est
beau en fait
c'est ça qui est beau
à et d'affilée une pièce en un
terrible
été complètement gagnant il est
tellement plus wesley c'est fou c'est
fou
c'est fou c'est fou
à elle est vraiment plus un
fait comme je t'ai la partie qui vaut 15
points mais tellement
gentil mais des points en fait la
dernière vaut 15 points et ça se joue
sur la fin mai
c'était
encore filer une pièce un
débutant je trouve ça sympa à regarder
enfin c'est que des pièces en lin frérot
un
raid championnat du monde de rapides et
bleed ce sera beaucoup plus sympa
en tout cas la fin de match ben c'est
terrible du fil des pièces en un il se
passe rien
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait la fille et la
dame
s'est tari ils font n'importe
iphone c'est thierry
bouikalo et sytrol total à
ste match
aller c'est magnifique quand il claque
encore heil a décidé de
je crois qu'il sait pas trop ce qui se
passe pas trop et que sais pas trop ce
qui se passe mais où
ils cliquent 1 voilà il doit être
content il ne reste plus qu'une derrière
a laissé la dernière game
il fallait un début et une fin
j'ai déjà mettre la petite cuve au moins
c'est fait
vous raterez peut-être là
la dernière quartier du coup à faire un
raid sur czech comme
c'était magnifique
par elle
le raid aussi pour voir les interviews
ça peut être quand même sympa
et faudrait un cesti car oui pour sauver
wesley
seule chance un
fin de la souffrance mais l'équation de
chasse sur aller les interviews on va
attendre la fin de la dernière game
le vis pas et n'en là j'ai plus
d'énergie 1 ça c'est fatiguant on a fait
en plus le speed run avant c'était sympa
la regarder ce match pendant quatre
heures
c'est pas le top 1 pour pour la forme
c'est pas le top
pressez sympa le petit speedrun avant
aurait espéré que ce soit la dernière
game
pour wesley
est pas que
j'avais encore la perle mais je pense
qu'il a intérêt à laisser tourner des 30
dernières secondes
oh non il abandonne il en refait encore
une
septième but elle s'accuse a fait penser
à du doubs bob tout craché dans les
fêtes c'est n'a pas du tout beau fly
juste à larache en fait
c'est pas du tout voire trop craché
c'est juste qu'ils cliquent complètement
au hasard de manière aléatoire
allez va se prendre le fou prend à vii
qui s'est pas pris depuis longtemps
et ça va finir là-dessus
sur la chaîne du talent tout craché
ouais
bah ça va finir là-dessus temps pointent
eux six ils menacent m'attend a chuté
sur fion premier gagne la dame ouest et
qui va abandonner
et on va se quitter là dessus basso est
cité pour le temps safra 23,8 ouest et
kia tilt jamais vu ouest et tilt autant
il abandonne pas finalement
peut-être maintenant non pas encore
ouais et voilà ils abandonnent il abrège
ses souffrances
et ça fait 23 8 donc je vous envoie tout
de suite leur aide pour les interviews
des joueurs et nous on se retrouve
demain pour un dernier live sur ma
chaîne avant avant des petites vacances
merci à tous d'avoir suivi passé une
excellente fin de soirée ciao ciao merci
à tous